Hello.
How are you doing everybody?
Welcome.
Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome.
To Devil May Cry 5.
Sorry, I was just looking.
Okay.
Hold on.
Look at, look at right here, Dante's head.
The little, the bar that highlights the continue button.
I was like, I was like, why did they make Dante look so weird over there?
Peek-a-boo.
Mike Wazowski, yeah.
For real.
But, yes, yes, yes, welcome back.
To Devil May Cry 5.
This...
We...
We shall finish today.
Yes!
If, if, if Virgil were to say, where's your motivation?
Okay, you guys, I have to tell you my motivation.
I have to tell you my motivation.
I recently...
Thank you, Joshua!
Thank you!
Yeah, I'm ready.
I...
I recently...
I think it was like, two days ago.
That's how recent.
There was...
There's a...
A yogurt place.
That opened up near me.
That I found out two days ago.
I don't know when it opened up.
But I found out about it two days ago.
And ever since I was...
Yesterday, I was like, I'm gonna go to that yogurt place.
And then, I forgot.
And so today, I was just like, I'm gonna go to that yogurt place.
But I have to beat the game.
Before it closes.
So, that's my motivation.
It's yogurt.
Cause I really like yogurt.
So, I'm gonna go to the yogurt place.
Yeah, I forgot.
I forgot.
But today...
Is yogurt.
Yes!
For the yogurt!
That's my motivation.
My Urizen.
My...
So, we're gonna kick Urgil's butt.
And...
Whoever else...
Is butt, we have to kick.
That's who...
Yeah!
I'm not...
I don't even know.
Like...
I don't know what the menu is.
But I've...
I've never seen a place like this before.
So, I was like...
I wanna go.
M-Zero, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Hope everything is okay with you and your friends.
Yeah!
For the other part...
I'd totally be down.
Um...
It's really...
Everybody's schedule is so, so busy.
Mm-hmm.
Ugh.
Hold on.
Let me...
I'm trying to scoot my chair.
Okay!
Yeah!
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Oh, yeah.
Howdy, howdy.
Welcome in, everybody.
Welcome in...
Hahaha.
It's a silly name.
Welcome.
Thank you!
So, yeah.
Hmm.
Are we ready?
I guess it's...
I guess I feel like I should just jump in, huh?
I feel like I should just jump in, maybe, no?
I just finished MDS1.
I understand now.
No crisp.
You understand...
A fraction.
You don't understand...
Keep going.
You...
Two.
And then you get to two and you're like, whoa.
I need to play three.
Then you're like, whoa.
I need to play four.
I need to play Peace Walker.
The rest is optional.
Hahaha.
People have probably asked if you have any plans to play Bayonetta in the future.
Also, IP dog!
Thank you so much for the 10 gift.
Thank you!
Um...
Any game...
For like, most game series...
It's never like a...
Like...
There's only a few...
A handful of games that I have like...
Actual plans to play.
But honestly...
Anything's up for grabs with me.
Hahaha.
If someone asks...
If I have...
Like this goes in full general.
If anybody is ever like, do you have plans to play?
XYZ.
It's really just like a...
It's like a...
Yeah.
Like...
Not plans...
Plans per se.
But like...
Anything is...
Anything is good to go.
You know?
Sometimes...
Sometimes I'll be like, I have plans to play a certain series or a game or whatever.
But I'm just like, not feeling it in the mood exactly.
And I'll play something else.
Instead...
That kinda happened with Half-Life.
You know?
Like...
I didn't have plans to play Half-Life.
But then I did.
Because it was just kind of like a...
Interest rather than plans.
Yeah, I think that's a better way to put it.
I have interest in pretty much anything.
Hahaha.
Now that you're almost done, how do you feel about the DMC series?
I love DMC!
Hahaha.
But I really wanna know how this ends...
How 5 ends.
Metal Gear Muffin!
Welcome to Mammalshift!
Thank you!
Hmm...
So, uh...
Yeah.
So...
You know?
You can always ask...
You can always ask if I have interest in a game.
I'll be 100% honest.
I'll keep it real with you guys.
I'll keep it real.
You...
Are there...
Like I said though...
I can't think of a single series though...
That I would be like...
No.
Absolutely not.
I don't know.
Hmm...
You should play Kingdom Hearts!
Just looked up Sora's VA.
Hahaha.
But right now is not the time to be doing...
Video game...
Talking.
Well, I mean...
I'm playing video game.
But the video game recommendations...
Now is the time to be playing video game.
So...
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
What did you do, Umi-Neko?
Hahaha.
Umm...
Uh...
Currently...
No.
Because I would have to read everything.
Wait, is Umi-Neko fully voiced?
If it is, that's insane.
First of all.
No.
There's no way it is.
I would have to read everything.
And do you think my voice can handle that right now?
Hahaha.
Heck no.
It is?
It's actually fully voiced?
Oh, not fully.
Okay.
I was gonna say...
Wait.
Huh?
Help everyone is friends at the end and they live in a big house like a Sentai team.
Hahaha.
Hmm.
Pretty much fully.
That's insane.
Obviously not in English.
Yeah.
So then I would have to...
Read it out anyway.
Which is, uh...
Oof.
Yeah.
No.
Maybe not right now for me.
Hahaha.
No visual novels...
For me currently.
Hmm.
Did you see the demo for Toho 20?
I...
Don't think I saw the demo, but I saw it was announced.
I did see.
It was announced a little bit a while ago.
Hmm.
Okay.
Are we ready, guys?
Are we...
Ready?
Mission 13.
We have...
Hmm.
Eight.
Eight missions left to go, baby.
Three warriors.
Eating Mike Tyson's ass.
Thank you!
For the dead captain.
Okay.
Will you watch this, but...
Um...
I must watch it again.
Hahaha.
I must...
Watch this again.
Well...
Looks like no one's worse for wear.
I'm just gonna double check.
Lady's so cute.
Gosh, she's so cute.
I wish she had more screen time.
Give Lady more screen time.
Hey.
Where'd that garbage god go?
What is Urizin after?
Urizin.
He's at the top.
Of the Clyphod.
It's the other way around, Dante.
This is the lowest level of the Clyphod's upper echelon.
Human blood is the source of demon's power.
The fruit born through the Clyphod is even more dense...
Gotta give it to Virgil's clothes.
Hahaha.
Its power is unparalleled.
Even the almighty Mundus used it to become king of the underworld.
Avid told me everything.
Yeah, well, that's a lovely story and all, but...
As long as we know where to find him.
I guess who Nico's dad is.
So...
Whoa!
You...
Are the infamous Dante!
That's assumed...
That means I know...
That means it's a character I know.
I'm Nicolette Goldstein.
Tell familiar?
My grandmother is...
Is Nell Goldstein.
The gunsmith that made all your fancy weapons that you got...
Trapped back there.
Hottest character in the game?
Who?
It's Nero!
You don't much look like her.
Yeah.
I got my looks from my daddy.
That's about all I got from him.
But based on his research...
Her dad is Angus Beef?
Um...
Consider it a gift.
In honor of us finally meeting.
Where was she in four?
Meeting.
Aw yeah, baby.
Time for it to happen again.
For those wondering, we watched this literally yesterday, so...
Oh god.
Why does he do this?
Why is he...
Why is he hoot and holler?
Oh!
Actually, I shouldn't even...
Why am I saying why?
I love Nico.
She's like so excited for his stuff.
Everyone else is like...
Trish is like...
I'm gonna go too.
Why don't you sit this one out?
Don't call me dead weight.
No thanks.
I've got all the power I need.
Right here.
You don't understand.
It's not what I mean.
Let him go, Dante.
Time is a luxury that we can no longer afford.
Fancy glove.
Don't call me dead weight.
Oh god.
V.
Hehehehe.
Well, that's all you had to say, Mr. Poetry.
I'm gonna go my way, and you guys can go yours.
Let's just say that's the best for the cause.
Peace out.
Sorry if you can hear me chewing my cough drop.
Yeah, we need to give V a better skin care routine.
His skin barrier is damaged.
Whee!
Okay.
You could call him a...
Flake?
Hey!
Hey V!
Don't...
Flake out on us!
Yummy mentioned you dancing off camera so I can imagine you doing...
I just... I just move around a lot.
I just wiggle.
I can't help it.
Alright.
First VTuber I've ever joined in membership of Super Chatted.
Woo!
Thank you!
Woohoo!
Thank you so much!
Hold on.
Implication that the only thing stopping Virgil from absolutely covering himself in tattoos is his demon side.
Hm?
Oh yeah, you're right.
You're right.
Yeah, his humanity side has like all the tattoos and stuff.
What's up with that?
He's such an emo guy.
Alrighty.
So I'm gonna play as Dante.
Teare...
Wish we could see more of Virgil...
W-when did he get so into poetry?
If he weren't a demon, you know, you could see him like at...
Like a... a jazz club underground basement.
Like reading off his emo poetry.
He's a secret emo.
Oh yeah, lady.
You're so cute.
Alright.
So we just got the hat.
So let me go into the void.
And um...
Wait, where is the hat?
Oh, Dr. Faust.
Here we go.
Man in the red.
No, that V.
Couldn't be V.
Carpet the area around you with countless robs that will damage enemies on contact.
Expends the robs you've collected.
But we get a lot of robs back, right?
We'll get a lot back, right?
Kevin, welcome back.
Thank you.
The black ink on V's arms and hair are his summons.
Oh.
Makes sense.
Inflict damage on all enemies hit by set hat.
While absorbing robs.
After executing a set hat or mad hatter.
Okay, I'll have to look at the...
I'll have to look at the...
What's it called?
The...
The list of...
The skill list.
Increases the orbs earned and orbs expended while Dr. Faust is equipped.
Uses more orbs for more attack power.
Okay, okay.
Alright, let's...
Let's try it out, I suppose.
I'll try!
I'll try this one.
Oh, okay.
We are being left stick back X.
Okay.
Does it work like a gun?
Oh...
Thank you for the five kids.
Thank you!
Oh...
Why should I put on my cowboy hat?
Okay.
Pick him up.
Pick up my brawars!
Oh my god.
Whoa.
Okay.
This is evil.
To make me, forcing me to use my own money.
Who are you talking to?
Oh my god.
The idle pose is too, is too much.
Oh, Gunslinger move.
Oh... There we go.
Whoa!
So it's like a...
What?!
He's got the hat on!
Why is he wearing the hat?
Wait, why is he got the hat on?
Does this produce rorbs or...
He's rooting too!
Now I need to see every enemy with the hat on.
Including...
Hold on, I think this one will be really silly looking.
Okay, here you go.
It's floating above your little head!
Wait, this is so funny!
Oh wait, these ugly skellies are gonna look so stupid.
Okay, here you go.
Wait!
He looks like a rock star!
Wait, it actually suits him!
I said you'd look dumb, but it suits you!
Aw, man.
He looked like a rock star.
It actually looks good!
Oh my god!
Cause it looks like the...
The little, like, head part...
Is his hair.
He looks crazy!
He looks cool!
Oh gosh!
Who else?
Wait, I gotta see a lizard with a...
There's one enemy we have yet to encounter.
That's kinda freaky.
Okay, kill me up.
Here's...
Here's your hat!
What the?!
Why are you fighting me?!
Oh, shoot.
I think I turned on the wrong setting.
I'm not ready.
I'm not...
Keep me...
Take your hat!
He looks kinda cute.
Dang.
Okay.
Oh, let's leave the void.
I think we're good now.
I understand.
Okay.
Oh, I have 37.
I've leveled up all my sword master, which is great.
We've got...
Balrog.
I haven't really done...
I haven't really upgraded him, even though I use it a lot.
Upgrade SDT.
Oh, this?
Wait.
No, this is just a double...
Can I...
Oh my god!
Drive is back!
Where is it?
Oh!
Here we go.
Sin Stinger!
Ho ho ho ho!
Oh my god!
Sin Inferno!
Demolition!
Oh my god!
Press and hold LT!
Grab an enemy and trigger a blast from within.
Shattering the enemy with raw explosive power!
Slam a thunderous punch into the ground, making the fires of hell erupt around you and launch any nearby enemies into the air.
Quadruple S.
Yeah, it just looks like a...
Wait, hold on.
Let's try it.
Oh my god.
Oh, come on game.
Give me some DT.
Give me some...
Man.
I'm bored.
Settings?
Wait, can I do it in settings?
Player settings?
Recover...
Yes.
Oh, yes.
Unlimited!
Okay.
Nice.
Royal Guard Gage.
I don't even know...
I haven't even...
Sorry guys, I don't do Royal Guard.
So do I still have to...
There we go.
I'm holding.
Oh, left trigger.
I'm an idiot.
Oop.
How much does it...
Does it like use a ton of it?
Does it like use up my thing or...
Wow.
No.
It's just a black hole.
What?
Oh my god.
The bitrate?
Oh no, I'm sorry.
Nope.
It's just a timer?
Cool.
Wait, so...
I would have to get Stinger.
Since I don't have it anymore.
There we are.
Whoa!
Oh, that's right.
Uh, this button is...
Wait.
Oh, there's only one.
Okay, so this is a teleport.
Hold on, let me see.
Have an appointment to get to.
Don't ever apologize for not being able to stay.
Good luck with your appointment!
Try your...
Alt...
X plus Y.
Try holding X and Y.
Oh, that?
Oh, never mind.
This?
Holy cow!
That's my ult.
Okay, this...
I have to remember that this doesn't do anything now.
It's just a teleport, you know?
What did I do before though?
That, like that.
Oh, that's just X.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Yeah, you can't change styles.
I wish I could, um...
Add more enemies in the void, you know?
So I could see, like, kind of what the range is on it.
I wonder if I can.
Let's see.
Enemy setting.
No, it doesn't look like it.
Hmm.
Holding X does nothing.
Okay.
Just go to the other side?
Let's try it.
Meow.
There we go.
Okay.
Can you see me?
He's still standing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
It's not that far then.
So much for infinite range.
Yeah.
Right?
Everybody was just like, you can go as far as you want.
It'll hit.
This is why we do it for science.
Let's try, like, over here.
There's infinite, I said.
Hey.
I'm pressing him at the same time.
There we go.
Oh, there he goes.
There he is.
Okay.
All right.
You want to try it on again?
Okay.
Let's quit the void.
I think I kind of just want to...
Well, I want to upgrade these, but I also kind of want to just get into it.
But I'm also like, I want to upgrade these.
I think Sin Stinger would be good.
Right?
Try Luce.
Is that this one?
Focus energy with your outstretched wings and raise the earth with laser barrage.
Wait, hold on real quick, guys.
Okay.
Let's try it.
I just press RT.
I'll hold RT to keep the attack going.
Okay.
It shreds boss's health bars.
Give him a little bit of space.
Okay.
So if I hold it.
It'll just be...
Oh my God.
Easy mode is now selectable.
The skill.
Holy.
Oh my God.
Well.
That's a skill.
But you aren't I framed.
Okay.
I mean, I have just a...
I feel like I want to at least buy the Stinger.
I think I want to at least buy the Stinger.
I can maybe save up for...
One of these.
I didn't try this one, but that's okay.
Hmm.
Stinger save up for demolition.
Yeah.
Either that or...
Is it...
Did I say it?
Is it Luce?
Is that right?
Luce.
Ooh.
The Lulu.
Is correct, Okob.
I think it's Luce like Lucifer.
The Luce.
Luce.
Luce?
Lucey like Lucifer?
Maybe.
I don't know.
Alright.
We'll do that then.
Who knows?
I might lose it all...
All of my money.
I might gain all my money back.
If I use the high.
Who knows?
Luce.
It's Luce.
You were saying it right.
Ok.
Luce Goosey.
The Lucey Goosey.
I like learning easy moves.
We're here for a good time.
Not a...
Crazy time.
Well, we are here for a crazy time.
Ok.
We got our bike.
We got our punch.
Let's just start the mission, baby.
Let's just get back into it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me back up at some point.
But for now, one foot in front of the other.
What?
You put me in front of a...
Oh.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say...
What?
Where am I?
Let's see.
What do I have?
Let's put our...
Let's put our fists on.
Oh my god.
The fists with the...
I guess it really doesn't matter what gun I have.
Okay.
In we go.
Oh, no.
Is this the...
The last enemy that is not...
On the...
Thing that I have yet to...
No.
It looks like...
Oh, it looks like the...
Ice guys.
But it's electricity instead.
Oh my god.
What are you doing to me?
Um...
Where are you?
Oh.
Go...
Go to him.
Where'd he go?
Oh.
I beat him up.
Put a hat on him.
That wasn't even...
He acted so tough.
I thought I was gonna be in here for like...
So long.
Can't see anything.
Woo!
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no, no.
Just gonna slice and dice that right in there.
Oh, I'm on...
Ouch!
Yup.
I'm just gonna do that.
There we go.
Oh my god.
There's so many things in here.
Okay.
Uh...
Where'd that guy go?
Woo!
Ouch!
Oh my god.
Oh
my god.
Oh my god.
Time to hat.
They just...
It hurts!
No!
It hurts watching my buddy go down.
I'll keep it on though.
Uh...
Hold on.
Sorry.
I'm trying to get myself situated.
Yeah.
There we go.
That's one guy.
Oh, oh, oh!
Yeah, that's...
Oh, yeah!
Where'd the big guy go?
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Did I kill him?
Nice.
Yeah, where did he go?
Oh!
The style is worth the sacrifice.
I guess...
Oh!
I think I found out where they went!
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
Ouch!
It does so much damage.
No, come here.
There we go.
I think I found out where they went.
Guys, stop yelling at me to charge my SDT.
I'm not gonna use it on a fight like this.
Oh, no, no, no.
No, no, get through us too!
Oh!
Oh, oh, I missed it.
There we go.
Oh, I think I got it.
Nice, okay.
What the hell is that eyeball?!
Oh, my God.
Okay, you know what?
I'm gonna D-team.
Just so I can take care of these guys.
Get some health back.
Where are you?
Where'd you go?
Beat him up!
No, no, no, the eyeball!
Eyeball's gonna explode.
Where the...
Oh!
I just noticed this one.
I'm so stupid.
Okay, cool.
I think it's producing eyeballs.
Or is it producing more lizards?
I can't...
Oh, golly.
Oh!
It just...
It just disappeared!
Yippee!
Oh, you are producing the eyeballs!
You're stinking...
A machine that produces...
I was stuck.
I couldn't jump.
It wouldn't let me.
Oh...
Okay.
I'm gonna die!
Yeah!
Come here, come here.
Oh, come here, come here.
I hate these eyeballs.
They're so annoying.
Okay.
Die!
Die, you stupid eyeball!
No!
Where'd you go?
Come here.
Yeah!
Stupid!
Woohoo!
Yeah!
Kick him!
Kick him where it hurts!
That's right.
You think?
You thought?
Die!
Thank you, Kim.
Yeah!
Destroy this thing.
And...
We got that one.
Woof!
Wait a second!
I was just sipping my tea!
Um...
Uh...
Okay.
Rude!
So rude.
Yeah!
Take that!
Uh...
Wait, where...
What's...
Do I go in the hole?
Oh, I thought that was an exit.
Wait, hold on.
There has to be something behind it.
No?
Guess we go in the hole.
Hole it.
Whee!
I can smell that piece of shit from up here.
It needs to be flushed.
What?
Give me more.
I guess we'll take this too.
It needs to be flushed.
Take that too.
So...
Ah!
Just a little bit more.
Just a tiny, tiny bit more.
Tiny, tiny.
Need more hat.
I'm scared of the hat!
What?
I'm scared of wasting my warbs.
I'm greedy.
Well, there's a hole there.
And...
Watch out Dante.
That's all there is.
It seems.
Only put it on them.
So a gunslinger put it on them and then return back to...
Wait, is there more than one hole?
I didn't see any others.
I only saw this big one.
This bad boy.
I don't see any other holes.
Wait, I don't need gunslinger to put it on?
But it was always B that I pushed.
X forward.
Forward X.
Oh, okay.
Ah!
Okay, okay.
He's stretching.
Sword Master 4.
Okay, fine.
I'll read the skill list.
Ugh!
I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna remember it.
I don't know what to tell you guys.
Oh god, this one I learned.
Forward plus B.
That's what I learned.
Okay.
RB.
Forward.
B.
Remembering optional.
See, my fingers just go...
My fingers just go...
Wait, I wanted to change back to punching.
Aw, shucks.
Wait, keep...
Keep doing it.
Wait, keep doing it.
Wait, I'm trying to destroy this thing.
Please!
Get out of my way, lizards!
Please, little lizards.
Wait, you guys said B.
It doesn't give it to them.
Oh, you said X.
I told you guys, I forget.
Sorry.
I told you I'd forget.
Oh, there we go.
I gave it to him.
I gave him his little hat.
I think there's another thing creating monsters.
I think it's over here.
Yes siree.
I heard you.
Don't try and play me.
I heard you revving up behind me.
Jump, jump, jump, jump.
Other side.
Yeah, okay.
Now...
I
wanna...
Oh!
Ow!
Jump...
Uh...
There we go.
Woo!
And it was...
Ouch.
Oh, it was a R.
I have to rip up for it!
I think!
Wait, hold on.
Oh my god!
You get my ass handed to me.
Okay.
I'll DT.
Where are you guys?
Oh, there.
You wanna touch me?
Ah!
There we go.
Oh!
Who's shooting at me?
Come here.
Oh my god!
Oh!
You son of a gun.
I'll give you...
A hat.
I...
I won't do that, actually.
I messed up.
Stop spinning!
Oh my god!
I gotta stop getting on the little hats.
I'm too obsessed with the hats.
Okay.
Can I...
Can I please, at least...
Please.
Oh my god.
Oh, you're so...
You guys are so obsessed with me!
Oh my god.
Who threw off my groove?
Kill!
Oh.
Get him!
Oh my gosh!
Oh!
Oh...
There we go.
Ay!
I like when I can...
Get
them out of their combo.
Is there another thing that... No?
Okay.
Come on.
Go after that guy.
Dodge, dodge, dodge, dodge!
Wait, where's your hat?
Oh, I forgot to press forward, I think.
No, you got a hat.
Ouch.
No, he's got his little hat.
He-he-he!
Yeah.
Oh, alright.
Oh, I... Ohhh, I hear them!
Like I hear them kind of like...
You can hear it kinda zapping.
Does that mean I have to pick the right one?
It's kind of like a game.
You have to guess which one you go to.
Or do they sometimes have things behind them?
You know what I mean?
No, just break them all?
Bust them all.
Okay.
I guess that's what... Oh!
Okay, I see.
It gets it rid of the... Okay, I understand now.
I understand now.
Now we go kill the Zappy Mushroom.
Okay, we kill the Zappy Mushroom.
Okay.
Alright, this one goes to... Somewhere.
No more... Fungi.
Your mold problem is... You know what, baby?
Maybe Dante really is a handyman.
Is there any fungus in here?
There... There's a Gorb!
Nice.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Also... Let's grab all of this, too.
Delicious health.
Thank you.
Okay...
Um... Did not get rid of... Oh!
Oh!
There's another hole!
What?
It got rid of another hole?
Or it got... It opened up another hole!
And we'll get rid of the... Electric Mushroom!
Before he gets me!
Nice!
Okay.
Secret Tunnel!
Honey...
Whoa!
We're in the honeycomb!
Secret...
Lots of Rorbs.
Thank you.
Many Rorbs.
Warbs.
Nice.
Let's go.
Oh my gosh.
It's a feast down here.
What does... What the... What would Pooh Bear say?
Did I... Did I get all of them?
Uh... I think so.
Wait.
What's in here?
Nothing.
Whoa!
Let's punch it to death.
I was worried for a second.
And then this goes back to the room we were just in.
Yikes.
I'm starting to notice a pattern with these rooms.
Oh!
Hello, V.
Hello, Nero.
Oh!
We're all together!
I don't think our hole led to the same place.
Looks like we still got a long ways to go.
Yey!
How bad!
Three warriors.
June 15th.
1 PM.
He's literally fading away.
What are you talking about?
He probably weighs like... He probably weighs nothing.
Oh god, V.
Can he reconnect with Urgil?
Can they re-fuse?
Fusion dance?
Come on!
Mission 14.
Oh, we're back to V.
Alright, I'm just not gonna buy anything.
I'm sorry.
But...
I might buy Porb.
I probably will buy Porb, if anything.
Porb always good.
Especially because I've been playing as Dante.
So he uses the devil trigger too.
Porb benefits everyone.
Kinda.
And then we'll leave it at that.
That's all we'll do.
I want to buy Blorb, but I will refrain.
I will refrain.
Alright.
V.
Let's get going.
Except the dead weight.
Okay.
Alright, V.
We got this.
Oh look, he's fine now.
He knows how to run.
He's fine.
See?
All good.
He's A-okay.
We're running.
We're...
We're doing skateboard tricks.
See?
He's faking it.
Oh.
Are you alright, V?
You might wanna take a break here.
No, no, no.
Oh, we're walking now.
Okay.
Dramatic.
What's in here?
Maybe drink it.
I'll make you feel better.
Whoa.
Nope.
Oh.
His tattoos!
His summons!
Oh.
Let's go.
Three for the price of one, baby.
Yeah, we got it.
I was... you know what?
Yeah.
Every DMC game has to have a beautiful, badass booby monster.
I'm losing my power.
Gotta recover somehow.
Recover by getting more, um...
Money.
Yeah, it's healing my... everything.
Yeah, look at that.
We gather money and we get...
We get better.
Yeah, look at that.
Ah.
Maybe money does cure all.
Money does buy happiness.
Come on.
V, it's right there.
V.
V, I'm gonna need you to make a really big...
Big boy jump here, okay, buddy?
Big boy jump!
How can I get up there?
Guys...
And over there, too!
This dimension is magical.
Honor DMC tradition, boss rush?
Please, no.
Please, God, no.
I know you're probably right.
I got Gorb.
It's only three bosses this time?
Okay, okay.
How do I get up...
Do I have to collect my bird?
Do I have to collect Griffin first?
Alright.
How do I boss rush?
Oh, I have to go through these portals.
Okay.
Okay, I'll...
Let me just look behind them real quick, V.
Let's just look behind and see if...
Oh, see?
There's a Yorb right there.
I mean a Warb.
Not a Yorb.
Oh, there's some more up there, even.
Does each one show a different thing?
Okay.
Oh, we got Phantom there.
Wait.
Oh, it shows...
Wait, is this the...
No.
This is the boss, isn't it?
Oh, golly.
Golly.
I don't want to fight that guy real quick.
Which one is the middle one?
Waiting for old V microwave hallway.
Middle is super easy.
Flying thing.
Artemis?
I'm gonna hold out on getting that because I...
We'll come back here, no?
So, I guess we'll try this.
The one that had Lady inside.
Why am I blanking so hard?
My babies!
I can get all three of them, right?
Wait, which is which?
Can I get all three of them?
Pick one?
What is this?
Pokemon!
Uh...
Pick a cat.
I can't even tell which one is which.
I can't tell.
Oh, it's Charmander.
It tells you if you get close.
Oh!
Free Shadow.
Free Nightmare.
What?
Nightmare would be best, no?
Free Griffin.
Or Shadow might be good.
No, he needs DT.
You're right.
I'll do Shadow.
Oh!
Oh, she was in the library!
That's right.
Oh, shoot.
Dude.
Wait, this fight might be horrible with Shadow.
Hahaha!
Ah!
How the hell am I supposed to do this?
Wait.
Oh!
Actually, Shadow does pretty good damage.
Go after her!
He's...
We're making some...
Okay, Shadow.
Okay.
Oop!
Oh, golly!
If I DT, what happens?
I am locked on.
I was locked on.
Hahaha!
Holy cow.
Maybe I'll just...
You know what?
Don't lock on.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Just do that, Shadow.
That's working.
That's actually working.
Yeah, yeah.
Keep doing that, Shadow.
Keep doing that.
Oh, shoot.
Just keep going.
Don't worry about me.
There we go.
Oh, that was easy.
We're not so...
Oh, uh...
And then I...
Gotta go in.
Oh, okay.
Get poked.
Hahaha!
We just were like...
We literally just poked her.
Oh my goodness.
That's so silly.
So then I should pro...
I imagine...
Okay.
I'm not gonna...
Be able to come back here after the third fight.
Unless...
Like this door opens.
But we just came out of there, no?
So I should get Griffin next.
Right?
So that I can get the Blorb.
Oh, I can come back here!
Yeah, I don't wanna fight this guy.
He scares me.
Hahaha!
Go Cavalier Angelo!
Aw, man.
He's tough.
This guy is tough.
Okay.
Cav is easy.
Well, I guess the lady...
She took like...
What?
Is Nero just the most weak man ever?
Hahaha!
Wait a second.
Oh no!
I didn't realize and I ate up all the gorbs that are around here.
Wait, maybe we can find some more.
I ate up all the gorbs that were in here.
There were some in...
What's her name's area too?
I just forgot to put...
Pick them up.
Nero is baby.
Poor guy.
He felt so strong when he had the grabby grub.
Okay.
We'll just get some in here maybe.
Cool, I can at least...
Oh my god!
Already?
Oh, oh, oh.
You scared me!
I thought he was summoned.
Alright, Griffin.
Oh wait.
Wait, Griffin or...
Or Nightmare would be better here.
Get the bird.
Okay.
Oh, there he is.
Should let you get the borbs.
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you so much for the raid!
Thank you, thank you.
Bird helps immensely.
Okay.
Let's do it.
My fingers are ready.
On X and Y.
I mean, I guess these guys are just sand too.
They look like sand just like us.
Oh my god.
Did he already die?
Who is...
Who is dead?
Oh my...
Shadow is dead.
Okay.
He's not doing anything.
There we go.
Oh, that's not good.
Yeah.
He's easy, they said.
Yeah, get his ass.
Oh.
Oh, and this is when he...
Starts charging.
Go after him!
Nice!
Take him out!
Yeah, take him out!
Where's my bird?
Oh, there they are.
Okay, bird's turn.
Oh.
Woohoo!
And my bird's dead.
I think Shadow did more of our damage.
Don't teleport.
There we go.
Yeah.
Get his ass.
Yeah, put him to the wall.
Put him to the wall.
There we go.
All right!
The way we aim.
There we go.
Oh my god!
That was crazy.
Woo.
Good job, V.
We stunlocked him.
Good job, team!
Alright, bird.
I'm counting on... Actually, maybe we should go from, like, here.
Oh, wait.
Can I... Like, get on top of this.
Thank you.
Nevermind.
Oh.
There we go.
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay.
Oh, no.
No!
I thought we could jump from here.
Um, maybe not.
Okay, wait.
Don't forget that standing near them... Orbs revived them past her.
Yeah!
Why do you think I was standing near them?
I know.
Oh, come on!
Come on!
Send me up!
Send me!
Grab me!
Grab me, bird!
Hold on.
Let me try again from over here.
Okay.
Let's try... Come on.
Come on.
I didn't let go that time.
Maybe I can get a little, like, here.
There we go.
Yeah!
Nice.
Okay.
Was there anything else in the sky that we needed to get?
I know there were the roars.
Okie dokie.
I don't think there was anything else.
Nothing in here.
Doesn't seem like it.
Alright.
Our final fight.
Just that.
This big ol'.
This big fella.
Let's go.
Nightmare time.
Yeah.
We'll summon him.
We'll summon him and just have him go to town.
Kaiju fight!
Do I need health?
We'll hold off for now.
So there's that over there and there's some warbs in here too.
There's two warbs?
Two warbs.
Okay.
Big boy fight.
It's gold!
Nightmare!
The immediate summon.
Fun.
Oh my god!
He's really big!
Big!
Holy cow!
Slice it, of course.
Oh wait.
Where'd the warp go?
Did I already collect it?
Uh oh.
Wait.
Pin it to the wall.
Uh oh.
Slice it.
You know what?
I'm gonna grab it anyway.
I see the other warp.
I could read.
Yeah, but this is free and fastest.
Look, he's already down.
Oh.
My turn?
These fights are like redeeming V.
He's so cool in these.
Yay!
Wow.
That's the boss rush?
In this game?
That's it?
Wow.
Yeah, they made it so easy.
Aw.
Okay.
Yes sir.
Oh no.
The best we avoided if possible.
Especially given my condition.
My condition.
You feeling better now, buddy?
Oh wait.
Get up.
Nice.
There we go.
And...
Yep.
Oh, dang it.
I didn't mean to double jump.
I wish it would just work like a skateboard.
Like I'm playing Tony Hawk.
And I don't jump off my...
My skate cat.
Whoopsie-daisy.
Alright.
Soaring the DMC crew!
Wait a second.
Where's my pals?
Where... where am I?
Where are they?
Where is everybody?
No time to worry about them, B.
Wait, I wanna see them!
I can't even see!
I hear...
I hear so much happening.
But I can't see anything.
Keep going down.
I'm trying.
Oh wait.
Kill it!
Slice them into the wall.
Yay!
They're below me, I know!
But I wanna see them!
I hear them!
Where are they?
Is that a mission?
Oh no I didn't.
Sorry.
Got it.
I'm greedy.
Wait, can I see them in here?
Who is that?
Nero?
Sounds like Nero.
Dead weight.
You guys are so mean!
There's a plorb nearby.
Where at?
Wait, in here?
Oh.
What is this?
Oh!
This is for...
Oh my god.
I can't believe I found a secret mission.
Is it in here?
Stop!
Cat!
My journey...
Is coming to an end.
We're on our own mission.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
We...
If he reaches the fruit, it will all be over.
Even Moody's failed to reign over the human world.
Surely no, he will not!
Malfus!
No way can we handle her!
We don't have the strength!
I know.
But we must get through this.
Somehow...
He's a bit of a weenie.
But I don't blame...
Oh my god!
The schnoz on that creature!
Ha ha ha ha!
He's like...
I'm just...
No!
I must keep my V card!
Chicken Jockey!
Niro's here to save the day!
Nice!
Niro to the rescue, baby!
That one was so fast.
That was such a fast mission.
Ha ha ha ha!
Damn it!
Running a little low.
Meanwhile...
It's much longer without a refill.
Yeah...
Oh!
I was gonna say...
Where...
Where's the Nico when you need her?
Hey honey!
Need assistance?
What the hell's your problem?
You trying to kill me?
If you wanna bitch, blame it on lady.
She's behind the wheel.
I love a lady behind the wheel.
Ha ha ha!
She's so cute!
Enough with the suspense!
What do you need?
I like her Lightning McQueen...
Uh...
Head...
Headgear.
He needs a hand.
He needs a hand!
Guys, before we do...
Mission 15, I'm gonna go grab some more water real quick.
I'm so sorry.
I just ran out.
BRB real fast, real fast, real fast.
Sorry about that.
It took longer than I thought.
Because I committed a sin.
I committed a sin.
Everybody.
My...
So I have a...
I have like a hot water...
I have a hot water...
Uh...
It keeps the water hot.
It's like a hot water dispenser.
It keeps the water hot all day.
And I forgot to refill it.
And...
And so I...
What is Lady doing?
Is she naked?
What is she doing in there?
Oh!
She just took a shower!
She's like...
Niko, I need a towel!
Cool!
Hahaha!
But um...
Anyway...
I uh...
I...
Um...
Forgot to refill the hot water.
And so I had to microwave my tea.
I committed a sin.
All right.
Mission 15, baby!
We're back to Nero.
Oh, golly.
It's been a while.
It's been a while since we've played...
Nero.
Ah...
Mmm...
You are not forgiven.
Haha!
How could you?
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry.
Minto Lady outfit.
What, naked?
I can't...
Haha!
Oh my gosh.
I just noticed Niko's like...
Her...
Tattoo...
On the...
Where the...
That...
Wow!
Oh, I never noticed it before.
I just noticed it...
That one.
Wow.
It's really cute.
Teeheehee.
Okay.
Let's see.
I think I should just give it...
Get back into it.
I think we can just kinda...
Have 93,000 Rorbs.
I think I can just get back into it.
Look at...
Oh, I was gonna say I almost have enough for this one.
I don't.
Minto Womb Tattoo outfit win.
Alright.
Let's just get back into it.
Mission...
Sudato!
Welcome back.
Welcome back...
Back at the...
Nier...
Ruuu...
Alright.
Thank you mash.
What the...
Okay?
Where are you...
Um...
Which road should I take?
Uh...
There's an arm over there.
Wait, how do I even get to the other path?
What, do I just drop it down?
No.
He showed a second path and I can't even find...
Oh, it's in there!
I see, I see it.
Ah!
I see, I see, I see.
Um...
Uh...
Ugh...
I feel like...
This would be...
Better?
But this one has Roarbs.
Ha ha ha ha!
Porb in the upper, apparently.
Oh, really?
Actually?
Spike...
Spike's is infinitely harder!
Wait, actually?
Probably more stuff on the upper path, but it looks more difficult.
That's what I'm thinking.
Hmm...
Reg time!
Oh, my God!
Ha ha ha ha!
I wish I had Trickster right now.
I'm sensing, uh...
Deja Vu here.
Wait, I can't see.
There we go.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, wait!
Who's down there?
Um, somebody?
Ooh!
More rag time?
Oh, gosh.
Why did I take this path?
I'm such an idiot.
Ouch!
Uh...
Why did I take this...
Oh, my gosh.
Where did you guys come from?
Yeah.
Wahoo!
Chou chou chou.
How did you recover so fast?
Wait!
Wait, I thought I killed that guy.
Another one showed up?
Ouch.
Whoa, where'd those come from?
Oh...
Who's got the Wormies?
Wait!
I just got rid of you!
Dude!
Oh, oh, my God.
Use the arms as if I haven't been using Gerbro this entire time like that.
What are you talking about?
Oh, my God.
Oh, shoot.
That sucks.
Oh!
God, I'm gonna die here.
Give me a break, guys.
It's been...
A minute since we played as Gerro!
Okay.
Wow.
I just wasted all my health.
Oh, my God.
At least this one...
Is kinda slow.
Okay.
Um...
I'm trying to get to the Grorbs over there.
Or not Grorbs, but you know what I mean.
The healing...
The healing troop!
I'm lost!
Okay, game.
Tell me where to go!
Oh, I'm going the right way.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Oh, yeah!
How could I forget?
How could I forget my Rev?
All right.
There's some coffins.
I saw...
I saw a Rorb tree up there, but...
I guess this is the other way that we could've gone.
And this is the way that I chose.
Oh.
Hello.
I think it's the first time we've...
No!
You waited!
You waited.
I know you did.
Oh, my God.
Move, Nero!
Let's get airborne.
No, please!
Oh, that's so unfair.
Let's get airborne.
No, no, no.
I tried to leave, but I was airborne.
It's okay, I'll just restart.
All right.
They completely waited for me to be on the ground.
To do their spinny attack.
Those assholes!
Where am I?
Oh!
I have to do it all over again!
Fair enough.
Understandable.
Oh, thank you.
We'll go the other way.
We'll go this way.
Cross route.
Which way should I go?
Yeah.
Oh, hello.
Um.
But like...
How do I get across?
Where are they fighting?
Oh.
Hello?
Stinger from the ledge?
Like that?
Can I...
After it, hold on.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
No, I can't jump.
What is it?
Oh, it's giving me Gerbera.
So...
Maybe I'll use that.
Hold on, let me practice a minute.
Like that.
Okay, okay, okay.
It's down here.
Can I even make it over there?
Leviticard, thank you so...
Much for the...
Gifted!
Okay.
What's even down there?
Little losers.
Uh...
Nice.
Whoa!
Oh, it's a freaking...
Five!
I love DMC too!
I'm not going over there.
Wait, what's down there?
Yeah, there you go.
Wait, what is that?
Oh, it's just lighting?
Oh, okay.
Haha.
That's funny.
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Yup!
Oh, yeah!
Okay.
Heh heh.
Heh heh heh heh heh.
Oh, another freaking mat.
Freaking mat.
I know it probably wants me to like, stay in the air and use Gerbera to stay in the air and...
Uh, like, you know, do all that stuff.
But...
I refuse to listen.
I
have a gun, so...
Oh, golly.
Platforming.
Okay.
Some wasted Rorbs, but that's okay.
You know what?
I've already...
I've already Gerbera'd.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Where did you come from?
Don't do it!
Wait, I'm lost?
It's okay.
There's a tree right there.
The MC2.
Glib.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh!
I had shot instead.
The Rorbs.
It's fine.
We win some, we lose some.
Where are you taking me?
What's over here?
Oh, nothing's over here.
Alright.
Oh.
Send me.
Where am I?
Why does this one feel so much longer than the other one though?
Yeah, get away from me.
Come here.
Oh, that's me.
Oh my gosh.
What are you doing?
Come here.
Yeah, that's right.
Stop it.
Stop.
Are you winning?
I don't know.
What are you guys saying?
Oh my gosh.
Where'd you come from?
Go away.
Actually.
We got him.
Divinity statue.
What if I didn't make that?
Okay.
That's death, I suppose.
Haha.
Umm.
What's over here?
I...
I don't want that to happen.
No.
Dante has like crazy skills now.
Nero, you need to shut up.
Nero, you need to know your place.
Buddy.
O pal.
Friend of mine.
The ice guys again.
Nero is way over his head.
No.
Stop it.
You're not allowed.
You're not allowed to do your stinky moves.
These things are pathetic.
As soon as you start hitting them, they absolutely stop fighting you.
This one's a treat.
Hot dog?
What time is a hot dog?
Hey, maybe it's my best friend Boris' birthday today.
Could you say hot dog for him?
Boris, happy birthday!
Hot dog.
Heck yeah.
This is the other one.
Little circle.
Okay, onwards.
Was the other way just so much shorter because I fell?
Or...
Is this just the longest way possible?
Am I...
Gonna ignore that coffin area completely?
I'm so confused.
Rawhide.
That's the whip, right?
Ah, this again.
It was a trap.
It was a trap!
Holy cow.
Oh.
Where'd he go?
Come here.
Oh, I can't.
Yeah.
What'd you try to do, huh?
Oh.
Oh shoot.
You didn't try to do anything.
Right now.
Oop.
Let's get airport.
Right now.
Yep.
We'll get it.
I'm pressing left trigger.
Why aren't you even trying?
There we go.
Did he just despawn?
It might have...
Maybe?
Hahaha.
Alright.
There's a bunch of goop on the ground.
Me thinks...
I don't know what me thinks.
Things will come out of said...
I knew it.
Oh my god.
I was going to say me thinks.
It's the lady bug that gets aggroed.
The queen.
Oh my god.
Let's get airport.
Right now.
Ah.
Let's get airport.
Oh, I didn't even...
Heh.
Right now.
Ugh.
Oh, he's dead.
Maybe she's not here.
Maybe I lied.
Oh, there's more coming.
Oh.
Yeah, you.
Wait, come here.
Come here.
Oh.
I guess we'll just do that.
Hey, what are you doing?
No!
Bang!
Burn my double trigger!
Oh!
There she is.
No!
Don't do it!
On my double trigger!
Ouch!
Oh, shoot.
Oh no, that one's it.
Oh no.
Oh no, that one's... Oh no.
I knew it.
I knew it was gonna be like this.
So I knew it.
Okay, we got her.
Nice.
Okay, that's one at least.
But she becomes so aggroed.
Oh, shoot.
That sucks.
Okay.
Don't, don't.
Oh.
Come on!
You bitch!
I can't even see you.
Please.
Damn.
Oh, it's Tomboy.
Oh, oops.
Turn it off.
Yeah!
There we go.
Wow!
Yippee!
Anything up here?
It's so squishy.
Alright.
Doesn't seem like anything.
Pull my Mickey Trigger!
Oh, here.
Yeah, thank you.
Gosh, we have so many Roarbs now.
So...
Where the heck am I?
Okay.
Understandable.
Yeah, I know Tomboy's still on.
It's okay.
There's no reason to turn it off, is there?
Oh, another Tomboy!
Lucky day.
Did we kill him?
Is there anything left?
That's it.
Good...
Goodness.
Okay.
Onwards.
Wait, what is this for though?
Oh, if I wanna go up there.
Well, what is up there?
Another Tomboy!
Wait.
Okay.
Um...
Wait, did it just spawn more?
Or...
Something.
Somewhere.
Up there?
I think?
Do I need to go over there?
Or do I go this way?
Let's see what this way is first.
It might be a dead end, but...
What?
Starring me?
Where am I?
Oh.
Ah!
It's gonna show me as V!
And then I'm fighting this thing.
Oh golly.
Oh my god.
I don't think our Nero was doing this much.
What the hell is this thing?
I don't think Nero in the cutscene was doing all of...
Or not cutscene, but you know what I mean?
I don't think he was doing all of this!
Nice!
Oh!
Tomboy is so great!
I love Tomboy!
Oh wait, who's that?
Oh!
Is that V?
Me?
I sure think so.
Oh, where?
Oh!
What'd you say?
Oh, there he goes.
Me as...
Is that me as Dante?
I'm still curious.
What if I went up over in this area?
I wonder if I still can.
What's up here instead?
You know?
But I didn't want to miss out.
Let's see.
Oh, it was AI.
Aw, boo.
What can I say?
I don't remember playing.
Oh, gosh.
What's...
Is it worth it?
Oh, my God.
Oh, gosh.
Oh.
No.
Okay.
Pull this guy.
There we go.
That's what I was...
That's what I figured was gonna happen.
I'll save it.
My Tomboy!
I hate Hellbat.
I see...
Oh, my God.
I knew it was gonna happen again.
I'm not even gonna...
Come here.
I knew it was gonna happen.
I knew it!
I have tried the gun and I don't like the Tomboy gun.
I do not like the Tomboy gun.
Because I can't aim it very well.
Ow!
Oh, my God.
He's gonna explode!
Tomboy gun.
It's too difficult for me to...
Any kind of those guns that, like...
That...
You have to, like...
This is gonna sound so bad.
Any of those guns that you have to aim?
But you know what I mean?
Like, they shoot big ol' lasers.
And...
You have to, like, be really precise with them.
But you know what I mean?
Oh.
We got a blur, baby!
Nice.
Maybe it was worth.
Does this go back down?
Oh.
I sure hope so.
The answer is...
Yes!
Perfect.
Aiming with controller is a pain.
Yeah!
So it's just...
Not my favorite.
I thought I turned the motion blur off.
Do you guys see it?
I thought I turned it off.
Bit rate not helping.
Oh, sorry.
This area is probably bit rate hell, huh?
So cute!
Thank you!
Licorice land.
I don't like black licorice, though.
Oh.
Hello.
Nero.
You got this.
There you go, buddy.
What are you a pal of mine?
Nothing but an invisible wall.
Nice.
Oh.
I didn't mean to do that.
Um...
I still don't think I'm gonna...
What's...
What are we at right now?
What's our magazine looking like?
We have one tomboy.
What is our health...
Not health or skeleton.
Ragtot...
Rag...
Rawhide!
Uh...
What's this one?
What's the blue one?
Overture.
That's just like the regular one, no?
One tomboy on standby?
I guess we could.
Tomboy, I feel...
For me...
For my fighting...
I use it depending on the...
I was...
I thought it was definitely gonna break with those big ol' machete guys.
But it didn't.
You know?
It...
I was shocked.
I was shocked!
Um...
But sure.
I'll buy one.
We'll put her in.
Put me in, coach!
Oh, and I'm gonna put a Gerbera at the end.
Wait, but what if I find another gun?
You know what?
I'll put this one away.
Wait.
There we go.
Here we go.
No...
Yeah.
Hehe.
I'll crush you.
Oh...
I'm coming...
Oh, this is where we say V!
Okay.
That's funny.
Heheh.
But you're nothing more than an empty shell with no power.
You are as weak as your flesh.
Human.
Chicken jockey.
And we're in an arena.
This is so perfect.
Poor Nero is always being called weak.
Before I use my...
Ouch.
What are you throwing at me?
You stink.
Oh gosh, I keep trying to get out of the way of that.
What are you, what are you trying to, what'd you throw at me?
Oh, you threw me a...
Thank you.
Oh, okay.
Oh, shoot.
I haven't used this one very much.
Ah, gosh.
Gets me every time.
Oh, where'd she go?
Failure attempt.
B lended me a hand.
What are you throwing me now?
Wait, how do I...
I wanna use... I wanna time her out when she comes back.
Okay, here we go.
Now?
There we go.
Oh.
Wow, that was the worst...
...time to use it.
Wait, where'd she go?
No.
That sucks.
Ugh, I don't know how to avoid that.
I'm just like too close to her.
Wait.
Can
I...
Uh, wait.
Oh God.
How do I...
Oh gosh.
Oh my God.
Wait.
Ah.
I'm not gonna make this one, probably.
Most likely.
But...
Futile.
Oh, she says futile.
I was like, what do you mean failed attempt?
I don't know.
Gosh, I only... I almost wanna use a Gorb.
But it's okay.
Okay.
Try again.
Nice try though.
Yeah.
We'll try again.
As long as...
I just worry that it's gonna take us so back...
Like further back in the, uh...
In the...
Like the checkpoint is kinda far back, but...
Oh!
See, it's not so bad actually.
I don't...
Yeah, yeah.
It's right here.
Get in my way and I'll crush you.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Ah, too bad.
Okay.
Alright.
He gave us a arm, but I don't know where it is.
Futile attempt.
Where's the arm?
Oh, he hasn't throw...
Wait, no.
He throws it to me in the cutscene, no?
Hahaha.
Oh, oh!
Oh, I got his butt!
Whoops!
Ah, damn.
Whoa!
Oh, damn!
I lost him!
Oh, dang it.
I lost him.
Oh, there he goes.
Thank you!
Oh my god.
Oh, wow!
Not the time, B, please!
Not the time!
No, I'm stuck!
I'm stuck!
This is ass.
This is...
Wait, this is so unfair.
What is happening?!
I'm stuck!
Look!
I...
What?!
What just happened?!
I was completely stunlocked!
Oh!
That's so unfair!
No!
Hahaha!
Okay...
That's fine.
Yeah, we...
It was rigged.
It was rigged!
Chicken...
Combo...
Huh...
I didn't even get to grab the arm that he threw at me.
Okay...
Dang!
I felt like I was not doing poorly if I wasn't doing so bad that time, too.
Oh!
Ah!
Try it.
I don't...
No, V...
Don't...
I don't fucking trust you.
I don't want you to touch me.
Don't...
I don't wanna hear it.
Don't throw...
Don't give me anything!
Wait, get out of the way.
Oh!
Oh, I'm trying to get the rag time, but I...
The camera keeps changing on me.
Oh, there it is!
Hahaha!
Oh gosh.
Okay.
This will do just fine.
Yeah.
Oh...
Wait.
What do you...
What did you just throw at me?
Wait, I'm stuck again.
No, please.
No, please, God, no!
No, no, no, please!
Please, please, please!
Please, please, please, please!
I can't grab onto it!
Oh my God!
Okay.
I have to be able to grab the arm...
Before it starts raging.
And then maybe...
Get out of the way.
Or...
Stop it.
Oh.
Oh my God.
I was trying to grab onto it.
To like...
To, you know, like...
Get on top of it.
But...
It would not let me.
So...
That's...
Not something you can do.
I have learned.
And rack time is such ass...
Oh my God.
I'm dead.
Because I...
It doesn't...
It just shoots the bubbles randomly.
So I don't like it.
It's useful when the boss is stunned.
It's like...
If I can aim it...
Then it's...
Not fine.
Or not bad.
I get...
I get why he's throwing it at me.
It's for when he starts...
I have to do the...
Charged attack.
So...
I can avoid the...
I can avoid it when it's...
Running at me.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure that's why he throws it at me.
Oh.
That's not what I wanted to do.
Oh my God.
Oh.
Trying to leave.
I'm trying to...
Please.
Get me out of here.
I hate that cutscene.
It throws me out of the...
Groove so much.
It's so bad.
Why is there a cutscene for him to...
In the middle of a boss battle?
And now I'm fucking stuck.
Please let me leave.
It's so bad.
It's so awful.
Why is there a cutscene in the middle of a boss battle?
When did I become punchline?
Uh oh.
Oh no.
I didn't get it.
Oh no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
No.
I'm trying to leave.
I'm trying to get out.
Okay.
Oh God.
I can't see where the arm is.
I did best my first attempt.
This sucks.
My first attempt.
Why is my first attempt the best one?
That I've done so far.
So unfair.
Where are you?
I can't...
My camera angle.
Most boring match show I've ever seen.
Okay.
Oh shoot.
Ah!
Wait, move.
There we go.
No!
Please move!
Oh!
Do you want advice?
Nope.
I do not.
I already know what I need to do.
It's just a matter of me doing it.
Like I get what I need to do.
It's just, you know, as long as I don't get stunlocked or...
Or...
You know, properly can...
If I can find the arm that he throws me...
Oh wait, I have ragtime already.
So...
Okay.
Alright.
Get his butt.
I got a lock in.
Wait, what do you mean you're right there?
I know where you are.
Actually the camera doesn't really give me a choice.
I run, I run, I run, I run, I run...
Ah, shoot!
No!
No, please!
Oh, cutscene!
Why?
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Actually...
Oh my god.
Wait.
You almost got me killed.
Ragtime.
Is he about to go...
Psycho mode?
Can't tell.
I did no damage or I...
I got no...
Damage on me for quite some time though.
So that's not bad.
Oh shit.
Oh god.
Wait.
Oh shoot.
Shoot.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Please!
Charge.
He turned!
Exactly!
Are you kidding me?
That's so...
Wow!
Why did he... why did he turn and look exactly heavy?
I was just trying to dodge him!
Oh, shoot.
How did he know where I was?
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh,
come on.
I was like, why is it so blurry?
It's because I'm almost dead.
Guys, I might use a gorb on this.
I'm not gonna lie.
I might use a gorb.
We'll see.
I have 18 gorbs.
It's fine.
This guy sucks.
Okay.
Yippee!
Round two!
I hate that.
What's going
on?
Where'd he go?
Oh, I don't like that.
Oh, I don't like this.
Wait.
What are you doing?
I don't want to give up the ghost, do you?
Okay, that's gonna do.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
He's charging!
I feel
like he's not close even to being dead.
Oh, you jerk.
Oh my god, you jerk.
Landed right on me.
Sorry, sorry.
I'm getting frustrated.
Okay, that did good damage.
I tried dodging underneath him.
Fuck this.
I'm using another Gorb.
I don't care.
Gun her?
Oh, I guess that works too, huh?
Come here.
I don't care.
You're too close.
Because of the Gorb, baby.
Because I collected Gorbs.
You can come out now.
I guess I owe you one.
You should turn around.
Your body's not gonna last much longer.
That...
I cannot do.
I must go.
Goddammit, Bea.
Don't push yourself.
You need some rest.
I must go.
I don't think rest is gonna...
...solve this.
Why?
Why the hell?
I beg you.
This is my last request.
Fine.
Just carry him on his back.
It's on your back.
Dante's definitely gonna beat us there.
Good.
Let Dante handle it.
My cursor went right in the middle.
He could use some moisturizer, yeah.
I don't want... I don't want to play as Nero anymore.
Oh, I don't want to play as Nero anymore.
There's so much to keep up with with that guy.
He's got the different arms.
He's got the rev.
He's got too much stuff.
I don't want to be him anymore.
Nero, I used to like you so much, but not anymore.
Okay, let's customize.
Alrighty.
I like how Gorb is sold out.
Like I even never bought any.
I never even bought one.
Let's see.
What was I saving up for?
I can't remember.
Sad, dead weight noises.
Yeah.
He's living up to his name.
Oh, the Luce.
That's right.
You know what?
I can buy it and I still have over a hundred thousand.
Wait, I already learned it.
Wait.
Oh, sorry.
Yes.
Learn it.
Okay, we got that.
Hooey.
This one was just hold RT.
This one's hold LT.
Alright.
I'm just looking at what else there is.
Oh, yeah.
This one I didn't understand.
Hold on.
Let me exit here.
Oh, wait.
Can I not get to the skills menu?
In...
In this...
menu?
Like...
To see what skills I already have?
Oh, in the void I have to.
Okay, okay.
I have that one.
Ignition 3.
We could learn Ignition 3.
You got this minky doing good.
Thank you!
Let's see.
Skills list.
What was it again?
I learned...
What was it?
It was R...
No.
What was it?
Oh, heavy jolt.
On the ground.
Press R, V.
Forward, Y.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
But...
Wait.
There was something else I learned.
No.
I can't remember.
Hmm.
Oh!
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Well...
Luce.
I already know Luce.
You just hold down RT.
That one's easy.
We did that one earlier.
This one.
Yeah, you just...
Hold RT.
Before today?
No, it was today.
It's okay.
I think I remember it.
I think I'm okay.
It was something that I learned from...
Sword Master 4 or 3 or whatever, whatever.
And then, yeah.
I remember ult.
How to ult was Y and X at the same time.
Real impact?
Was that it?
Maybe.
Oh, one on one.
Real impact.
I did not see.
Is it in here?
Sword Master tab.
Oh!
That's why I was like...
I can't find any of the stuff that I learned.
Because it's all under here.
Oh my goodness gracious.
Okay.
Wheelie jump.
Press RB.
Back B.
Okay, okay.
RB.
Forward B.
Yeah, we knew that.
Mid air.
Press B, B, B.
Kick mode.
Mid air.
B.
Firestorm.
Kick mode.
B.
Blow mode.
Back.
B.
Okay, that's the one I was thinking of.
Okay, so I'm good.
Okay, alright.
Alright.
Oh, that stopped.
I pressed back menu too many times.
Okay, let's just carry on then.
Let's carry on.
Okay.
I think we can...
I think we'll be okay.
Wait.
Did I buy everything I wanted to buy?
I still have 100,000.
Let's buy...
Ignition three or orb?
What's igni...
Where's ignition three?
Is that under here?
No.
Wait, what's ignition three?
What was that one?
Under Balrog.
Did I miss it?
Oh!
Duh, duh.
Stupid.
Yes.
I feel I use this one enough that it is worth having ignition.
But hold on.
Uh, sorry.
My brain is...
Jello after that last fight.
Ugh.
My brain is jello after that last fight.
I'll do it.
Cause I can still buy...
A Blorb or a Porb.
Hmm.
You use it enough to be worth it.
That's how I feel too.
I wish I could see how many...
Fragments I had...
At the moment.
Usually it has it up in the corner.
Spend it all.
What I think I'll do...
Is I think I'll get...
A Blorb.
I'll get a Blorb.
Then we'll save up.
I can get a Porb.
And then I also wanna learn...
Next time.
Demolition.
So we'll do...
We'll go with those two maybe next time.
Porb and Demolition.
No more Blorbs for sale!
It didn't say that!
Wait, did it say it sold out?
For good?
Oh my god, it sold out for good!
You're right!
Stock zero.
Oh shoot.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ruh roh.
Oh, I have two out of four...
And one out of four for the Borb.
Okay.
Let's go!
Mission sixteen!
All Blorbed out.
We gotta go find some now.
Oh my gosh, I'm back...
I'm back here!
In the holes!
Wait, is there nothing around here?
Nothing around here?
Just a hole!
Whee!
Alright.
This is the real deal.
It is?
Hasn't been the real deal since now?
What have I been...
Full speed ahead.
Has this been a joke to you, Dante?
Until now?
Full speed ahead.
Yeah.
So true.
I guess everything's kind of a joke to this guy, huh?
Oh!
Oh, I missed some...
Some...
Warbs.
Oh!
Nice.
Collecting on the way down.
We're going down, down!
Lee-boo-ba-ba-dee-bow!
You sure I didn't miss any?
No?
I think we're good.
Okay.
Baby, we're going down, spinning.
A hundred, blah, a million.
A number one.
Devil, trigger, cock it and pull it.
Where's the guys?
Am I not getting ambushed here?
Shocking.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, sissy.
These guys.
These guys kind of...
I was trying to avoid that one guy.
I knew he was coming up from behind me.
Woo!
Wait, where did you come from?
I don't like each other.
Oh my god.
Dodge, please.
That was not good.
Okay, at least we got that guy.
Can I go into kick mode?
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Unfortunate.
And we're stylin' and we're stylin' and we're stylin' and we're stylin' and we're stylin' and we're stylin' and we're stylin'.
Come on.
There we go.
And we're styling, and we're styling, and we're styling, and I'm running away and I'm running away...
Stylin'.
Yeah.
And I'm styling, and I'm styling, and I'm styling!
Woo!
And I'm parrying, and I'm parrying, and I'm parrying, and I'm...
Where do you think you're going?
Right here!
Oh, and I'm missing, and I'm missing.
I'm just being goofy now.
Oh yeah, I should've put the hat on him, huh?
Don't forget about the hat.
Does the hat make them drop more warbs?
Is that what it does?
Like, what's the point of the hat?
It dies, actually.
Okay.
Three, two, one, zero.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, no!
No!
Wait, wait!
I went too far!
I... I... Oh!
No!
I missed everything!
Wee, wee, wee!
Put my Mito trigger!
Have SDT ready?
Wait, you can't just have it ready.
You have to, like, charge it.
And then, when you release...
I wish you could just have it at the ready, and then be like, BAM!
You know?
Wah, wah, wah!
Oh, bats!
I freaking hate bats.
Oh my golly!
I'm just trying to...
I'm just trying to live here.
Oh, ouch.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
Maybe...
Hold on.
Let's, uh...
Let's reconsider.
Okay.
How do I want to do this?
You can charge your SDT without activating?
I can?
But I thought I needed to...
I thought...
What?
Just like that?
And then I hold off?
Oh.
Get near the hat.
I can't see it.
Oh.
There we go.
Wait, I think I give it to...
Woo!
The countdown!
I'm trying to get behind you, buddy.
Wait, I didn't give him the hat.
But I thought I threw it.
I tried.
Do I...
I did forward gun.
Maybe I have to lock on.
Is it RB?
Hold on.
Let's...
We'll attempt...
We'll test it next time.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh.
It's a lock on.
Okay, okay, okay.
That's what we...
That's what I did wrong.
My bad.
We'll get her next time, boys.
All my raw herbs that I could've gotten.
Missed.
Missed business opportunity.
Missed machine.
Uh...
I can't see anything.
Oh, where did you come from?
Oh, wait.
Uh...
You get a hat?
Wait, did it give it to you?
No.
Come here.
Wait, come here.
Where are you going?
Uh...
My business venture...
Did not work out.
It did do the hat.
For once it did it.
Oh.
My business venture.
I think he went down the hole, you guys.
I think he's a lost cause.
My...
My business is a...
Is a sinking pit.
You get a hat.
Wait.
Oh, there it is.
And you get a hat.
You get a hat.
There it is.
I wanna do just one of these guys at a time.
I'll get trapped by both of their mouths.
Holy!
Just keep going.
I'm styling.
Oh shoot.
Oh no, Dante.
You didn't look so cool in that finisher, buddy.
Oh, Dante.
Dante, your finisher.
Perfect, yeah.
Okay.
I'm gonna not mess up this one.
Okay, actually, I need those.
Okay, we can go from there.
To the tree.
Yeah.
Very good.
I wish I could give the tree a hat.
Okay, it's gonna break through.
And we're gonna go to this one.
We're gonna go to this one.
Wow, they're giving me so much...
So many orbs.
I should just DT in every battle.
I should just be DT-ing all the time.
I'm nervous now.
It feels different.
It feels...
Things have changed.
Things have changed with the DT.
I'm an ultra, mega, big, big guy DT.
Yes, you should.
Okay, okay.
I just like to save it for in case I need it to bust out.
Gosh.
I like to hoard it in case I get trapped.
DT has changed.
Oh.
I'm somewhere.
In this game.
Oh.
I messed that up.
Is this...
Oh, is this...
Oh.
Okay, this is when I had...
What's it called?
Oh my gosh.
This is when I had...
I had a tomboy.
I was kicking his butt.
Like crazy.
I was going sicko mode.
Yeah!
Oh, I forgot to give him a hat.
I can't see!
So, I look cool in both sides now.
I look cool in both sides.
Wait, so...
I'm ca...
Wait, is it still rev?
Like the...
My SDT?
Is it still charged?
It is?
I can't tell the difference.
Maybe because it's...
Because it's been like this color.
Oh.
What's this?
Nothing.
Whole light or nothing.
The red bar is full.
Oh god.
Awakari mash.
Oh, it's these guys.
I hate these guys.
Whoop!
Dang, they do a lot of damage.
There we go.
What?
No, I want this guy.
Oop.
There we go.
And I...
Hold.
And I start styling on him.
Wait, come here.
Come here, come here, come here.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh no, see, he grabs me.
I can't DT out.
There we go.
It's okay.
I don't even need to worry.
Wait.
There we go.
Damn.
Okay.
Yeah, just kick his butt inside.
Exactly.
Come on.
Oh.
Oh my goodness.
Whoa.
Dante wins by doing nothing.
Wait.
Look at this guy.
He's so cool.
Three, two...
Ha ha ha ha!
Dante wins by doing nothing!
I keep forgetting to give them their hats!
You guys can scream that at me, you can be like, Hat!
Minto!
Hat!
I'm not always looking at chat, cause you know I'm gaming, but...
I'll try and at least see that.
Oh!
Nice.
I don't wanna miss...
I feel like there's gotta be like a...
Minto hat!
Not right now!
Not right now, you guys!
When it's an appropriate time.
I'll try and do it first thing.
You know?
First thing, give everybody their party hat.
Second thing, kick their ass.
That sounds like a shirt.
Oh my god!
Have you guys seen...
So, Fangamer has one...
Devil May Cry t-shirt.
One Devil May Cry item in general.
And it's a t-shirt.
And it's so...
It's so Devil May Cry, it's great.
Oh wait, the hat is temporary.
It has to be done before you kill them?
Oh...
Okay.
Damn.
You have to go to the Fangamer site and look at it.
It's so...
When you see it, you're like, wow.
Oh, there's the hole.
Okay.
Oh god, I looked it up.
Isn't it great?
I think I can get one of these...
One of the things I wanted to get.
Oh yeah, demolition.
There we go.
What?
Oh.
I, for some reason, thought the porb was...
Less than 40,000.
Okay.
It's pure cringe.
It is!
It's so perfect.
No?
It's like the most perfect...
Devil May Cry t-shirt I've ever seen.
No.
Only kills...
Of the underworld...
May enter these gates.
He shall not pass!
Easy there, fella.
Hey, I remember stinky little pooch just like you.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah!
You insult me!
Vow, scented creature!
Oh!
Oh yeah, I remember.
Looks like your master's got you on a pretty short leash.
Okay, time to try Lucy.
Come on, little puppy.
I'll take you out for a walk.
Come on, let's go.
You have fought our king with the best, for I am king of the summer's tribe.
I got that trap for me.
But we will feast on your flesh and gnaw on your bones.
Yeah!
So, you're the strongest in the litter.
Looks like we're gonna need a bigger leash.
Come on.
Ooh, ooh!
Here I go.
Wait, was it left trigger or right trigger?
Oh my gosh.
Oop, oop, oop.
Wait.
Oh, it was the wrong one.
Wait, it's a left trigger.
There we go.
I missed it!
It was a right trigger, not the left trigger.
It's okay.
We just...
We...
...apply.
Seen these moves before.
Can I give him a hat?
Oh my God!
I gave him a hat!
He's got three little hats!
It's so cute.
Oh, wait.
Ouch.
Oh, here we go.
Okay, it's right.
Alright, it's right.
Oh my god.
Come on, come on, Dante, you got this.
Come on, just get an hit.
Okay.
That hurt me.
Okay, let them get too close.
Oh my gosh.
Ah.
Can I knock these back at him?
Oh, ouch, ouch.
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Let's try again.
Oh, okay.
I just messed up the first.
The first one.
My bad.
The ultimate.
Oh, yeah.
We could try that too, right?
That'd be crazy.
Neat.
There's some robs around here.
The ultimate I should do probably right before my DT runs out though, no?
Towards the end.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay.
Wait, was I charged?
Oops, I didn't notice.
He's gonna pose.
It's gonna be really awesome.
Yeah.
Yeah, we...
I'm gonna...
Ooh, take some.
You're a bit tougher than the rest of your breeding.
Perfectly executed.
Yeah!
Woo!
Nice suit.
Oh, come on.
Even in the air?
Oh, I see.
I see how it works.
Okay.
These suck.
Oh, why am I on that?
No, no, no.
Hold on.
Can I...
Oh, I can at least fight them.
I can, uh...
Okay.
I can get rid of them.
Before they...
Okay.
Jump, jump, jump.
Ooh, oh shoot.
Not bad.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Ooh, that was so close.
Dog.
Come on, jump.
Oh.
Already?
We're getting rid of the...
Woo!
Oh shoot.
Just a little bit more.
Ah!
Oh, gosh.
That one's tough.
To dodge, rather.
Yeah.
Alright, it's okay though.
And...
Hooah!
It's okay.
Oh.
Oh no!
I missed the ultimate, but it's okay.
He's almost down.
Eh.
Back up, back up.
It's
okay, I got it the first time.
I saw someone tag and shoot me.
Let's get a little bit closer.
Oh!
Ow!
Dang it.
I guess, uh...
Let me change my...
Let's change too.
Wait, uh...
There we go.
Okay, we're going to freeze mode, I think.
Why can't I get the last one?
There we go.
Woop!
Okay, we're going to freeze mode, I think.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I've played these games before.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
I've played these games before!
He's almost there.
Come on, Dante.
Just a little bit more!
Just a little bit more, Dante!
Yeah!
Oh, I forgot the hat.
I did it before.
I forgot.
It's okay though.
Don't worry about it.
Yippee!
Wow.
Lucy is crazy.
Oh my god, finally!
I missed you.
Guess I'm the first one here.
I like that.
Three-in-one weapon.
I'm afraid.
I'm afraid of how this is going to work.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'm gonna go get some water real quick.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Yo, King Cerberus.
The power of King Cerberus dwells within this shape-shifting weapon, and charging attacks with ice, fire, and lightning in each form.
Twirl freezing with Y in Swordmaster.
You wield a blazing rod with B, or hold and release B to unleash an electrifying three-section staff.
Oh, boy.
I think that was super stylish today.
Ha, ha, ha.
The truth is...
I wanted to be protected...
and loved.
No...
But I was alone.
My only choice was to survive.
Oh...
V...
You gotta rest.
Miro...
And I will tell you...
Everything...
There is no demon...
Huh?
Named Urisen.
Wait, like...
Cause it's...
Only a man...
Yeah.
Who threw away his humanity...
But it's not...
In an endless pursuit of power.
But his name...
Is...
Yeah, cause it's just Urgil.
Oh...
He is Dante's older brother.
No...
Dante's...
Brother?
Yes.
Urgil...
And his real name is...
Huh?
Virgil...
What the?
Brothers...
Virgil...
Wait, is that their house?
Am I gonna fight Virgil?
Oh gosh.
Oh no.
Let's buy a pour real quick.
And everything's out of stock, baby.
Did you miss Virgil?
I don't know.
Do you feel ready?
Uh-uh.
Uh...
Asked a question in a super chat.
Just as you were leaving.
Oh...
Uh...
Hold on.
Planning to leave a spoiler-proof comment...
Listing everything DMC5 carried over from DMC Devil May Cry.
Unless you don't want me to.
Uh...
I think, uh...
Once I end the game, it'll be okay.
Probably.
Since I'm still not sure if I'll play DMC Devil May Cry yet.
But thanks for asking.
Um...
In the future, you could always ask in comments too.
You don't have to send money to ask.
Because I read comments.
Missed so many missions.
What have my grades been?
Um... I...
Uh...
Well, it doesn't matter.
Because C's get degrees.
Doesn't matter.
I'm passing.
I think I probably have all that...
Well...
I haven't even...
You...
Revolver.
I haven't even used Cerberus yet.
So I don't know if I want to...
This is always a...
This is always a staple...
Oh my gosh.
It's a...
I remember.
From before.
4.0.
So...
You're gonna hate this boss.
If it's anything like...
Virgil in 3...
Yeah, I'm gonna hate it.
Hahaha.
Wait, so...
What mission was this?
No.
Okay.
17...
18...
Wait, 17, 18, 19, 20...
Okay, so still...
Four more.
Alright.
We got this.
I think I started what?
At 13?
Yeah.
Four more.
I'm just gonna go into it.
Worries.
That means no worries.
For the rest of your days.
Ooh, apple.
Virgil.
Hey!
Is that the damn fruit you've been jabbering about?
Doesn't look so special to me.
A plee plee.
Why can't they just be friends?
This is where it all started.
That day mother saved me and...
Left you behind.
The thing you don't know is...
She tried to save you too.
She kept searching and searching.
Until I killed her.
I have no recollection of this tale.
Or this place.
It's all an illusion.
Created...
By this extraordinary fruit.
I look so juicy.
It's power, you see.
Is all I ever wanted.
And this...
No.
No!
I...
Will have...
Everything!
Yeah, take a big ol' juicy bite.
Ooh!
Oh my gosh.
I wish that were me this entire...
This entire like...
Level.
Oh no!
Woo!
No brother!
Ha!
You don't have everything!
No brother!
That last shred of humanity that you still had?
You just lost it.
Oh...
He's shedding!
He's...
It's molting season!
And then...
Oh...
Oh golly.
Woohoo!
Oh gosh.
Okay, Urgil.
Scat...
Alright, come...
I'm...
I'm afraid to get close to him.
Wah!
Okay.
Oh!
Damn, he hits hard.
I could try this.
Kick him instead?
Woo
woo woo!
Wait, you...
Ow!
Where's my...
Where's my kicks?
There we go.
Give him the hat!
Oh, where's my hat?
Oh, wait.
There it is.
I lost my hat.
Oh my gosh.
I'm just running around in circles right now.
I'm trying to read him.
Oh, right in the nuts!
Ouch!
Oh my god, I'm trying to get up.
Don't kick me while I'm down, bro.
That's not very kind of you.
Wait, where am I?
I can't even see.
He's so tall.
Stop punching the ground!
I'll kick you back!
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Let's try this.
Oh, I'm gonna get...
Yeah!
Uh-oh.
It was a little far away!
That was close.
I'm gonna go back to rebellion.
Stop.
Oh my gosh.
I wish... Do I heal in SDT or no?
Do you heal in... Oh, it's not rebellion.
You're right.
It's the... What's it called?
Only in normal DT.
Okay.
Good to know.
Yeah, it is a good reason to use normal DT.
Devil's sword daunting.
Sorry.
I said rebellion.
Rebellion's gone.
It's my bad.
Okay.
Let's try again.
No more rebellion.
Yeah, Dante is using Dante.
Oh my god.
It just sticks me in there.
I don't think... I don't think he liked my hat.
I don't think he likes it.
Wait.
Let's see.
And then he tried and kicked me.
Oh.
Ow.
Damn.
Oh, I ran right into that one.
And
he totally missed it.
You got... You weren't paying attention.
I put the hat on him already.
Yeah, I did.
Oh, I laughed about it.
I
forgot that I have the hat on.
So I'm losing Rorbs when I do that.
Hold on real quick.
I know I'm running in circles.
I'm gonna...
Woo!
My brother's got moves.
All right.
Now we'll save up.
Oh!
Ah!
Damn!
Oh, you sucker!
You sucker!
You suck!
It's like going in between his legs.
Okay.
I change.
I change weapon.
Oh my god.
I'm just trying to...
I'm trying to get DT...
While I'm...
Away from him.
Oh, air taunt.
Yeah, true.
I threw the rose.
Oh!
Oh, that was close.
Oh, he's so fast.
And then he kicks me in.
Because I have to like get...
I know.
Because it's a good position to not be...
Hit...
Not be punched by him.
Okay, like here.
But then he kicks me!
But if I'm in the air, then it's okay.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
What's he gonna do?
Can I hit this?
Was it that I...
Ow!
Okay, no.
No, don't try.
Don't try to do that.
Hahaha!
I'll challenge, I'll...
How?
How did he hit me?
I was running!
Alright, it's time for the big boy to come out.
Ow!
No!
Please!
Oh!
I missed it!
I missed...
I'll try...
I pressed X and Y.
Didn't work.
I feel like we got so far.
One more try.
We can do one more try.
I only get so far because of Lucy anyway.
Hahaha!
I only do...
I only get so far...
I wanna save as many Gorphs as I need to for the...
For the last bosses.
You know?
You'll need the Gorphs later.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
That's not what I meant to do.
Hahaha!
I'm gonna give you a hat.
Oh god, no.
Guys, we're not starting off very strong.
Um...
Not starting off too strong.
It's okay.
It's my fault.
Hahaha!
Come on!
Please!
At least he can only kick me or...
You...
I hate this guy.
He's such a...
He's such a squirrel.
Guys, not...
We're not doing so great.
Guys.
Guys!
Guys, I'm struggling.
Guys, I'm struggling a little.
Hahaha!
Is airbite gonna be that much of a difference?
I wonder.
Guess I can get a couple hits in there.
Oh!
Let me try it.
See!
He just backs up!
Hahaha!
He's just like...
What are you trying?
Give me that with that part.
Yeah, I wish I'm here.
It's actually me.
He's asking that to me.
Hahaha!
Dante, I don't want to hear it.
Oh!
Oh, but I got hit him, man.
I wonder...
Please come back.
Should
I...
Man.
I'm bored.
Hahaha!
Swordmaster only run!
Oh!
Wait.
Oh, don't kick me.
It's nothing.
I'm useless.
Shit!
Don't try to hit the thing.
It feels good to taunt and then actually dodge the tank.
What weapon am I on?
Okay, let's get back to this.
Me too.
Run away, run away, run away, run away.
Dante, no, oh no.
I tried to get out of it.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, I didn't see them.
Oh my god.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, but I want to use a big move.
Okay,
get up to him.
There we go, there we go.
Oh my gosh, that camera angle change.
Alright, I'm gonna...
Time to use the big boy.
No, never mind.
It's not time yet.
Oh my gosh.
Dante, just a little bit more time, please.
Once I...
Once the birds were out of this thing.
Okay.
Alright, there we go.
Time.
Okay.
Just a little bit more.
Oh my god.
Nope, nope, nope.
Not yet.
Holy cow.
I didn't notice.
Oh, good.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, I'm taking so much damage.
So cheap.
I'm in slow-mo.
Ahahaha.
Um.
Oh, what is this?
Because I'm not good, baby!
They're brothers?
Why are they fighting each other?
To see one's justice through, a man must fight for it, even if the one who stands before him is his kin.
That's ridiculous.
The Brothers of Blood disagree on the very reason of their existence.
They must fight.
Swordmaster only run!
Daunte 3, Virgil 0.
Doesn't feel that... Mentally... Mentally, Virgil 3.
You're late.
Just finishing up.
Is that really your brother?
I'm afraid so.
So he was behind all this.
You know, flesh and blood.
Doesn't look like much flesh there.
Fusion dance!
In the last throes of defeat, I see...
You...
Yeah, get his ass, V.
Get his ass!
Things are about to get really messy.
Oh my god, the sky is like even breaking apart.
No, please...
Their little fantasy illusion world.
V needs some milk.
He looks actually better this way.
He looks like a lizard.
I like lizard V better.
I like
the illusion of shattering.
Oh my god, quit groaning, Urgil.
He's just moaning and groaning down there.
Not lose.
Round two.
Not Adante.
I need power.
More power.
Wait.
Yeah.
What's happening?
Oh no.
No, Virgil.
I mean...
Wait.
No.
V, no.
Oh no, no, no, no!
Stop him!
Stop the dust man!
Oh no.
Oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
Oh, ah!
What is this?
Virgil.
That's his brother!
Oh my god.
Virgil!
The Alpha and the Omega.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Happy birthday, Matt!
We're back in here.
But we fought together before.
We did.
Oh my god, it's his book.
Full of jokes and puns.
He has come to Urgil.
Holy...
We fought together before.
We're family!
Oh my god.
Defeating me like this.
That's no meaning.
Come on, Virgil.
Let's do this.
Defeating me like this.
Heal your wounds, Dante.
Get strong.
After that, we'll settle the matter.
Oh my god.
Yeah, Dante's like...
so out of breath.
Zandatsu.
Thank you, Nero.
Yeah, because if Nero hadn't brought V...
He would've just died.
What happened to V?
Um...
He returned.
To himself.
Oh my god.
Go home, Nero.
This doesn't concern you.
Like hell.
Oh, I think it does, yeah.
I lost my right arm because of him.
This is not your fight.
I need to stop him and that's all that matters.
I'm not gonna let you have all the fun, Dante.
You don't get it.
Let me guess.
I'm dead weight.
That's not it.
What is this?
He's your father.
Luke.
I had the feeling the first time I saw you, but I just wasn't sure.
And then I saw how the Yamato reacted.
And I was certain.
He's your father.
Now he needs an ass kicking.
But I can't have you go kill your old man.
Aww.
What is this?
Metal Gear?
Sons killing fathers?
My father.
Unless...
Woah!
Now it's in space!
The world's biggest dandelion in space.
Wow!
Damn!
That day...
If our positions were switched...
Would our...
Fates...
Be different.
Who is the mob?
Would I have your life...
And you mine?
No, no,
no.
Let's settle this...
Dante...
What's the chair?
Huh?
Why are you guys all saying the chair?
What...
What's happening now?
Oh god.
I thought it was over.
This isn't good.
What are you guys talking about?
It's a meme?
Oh...
She doesn't know!
I've never played this game before!
Have you not seen the meme?
No!
Cause I...
Have not seen anything about this game before!
Well, now you guys are just making me feel bad.
Okay...
Kalina Ann too.
Let's go!
Oh!
Double Kalina Ann!
Let's go!
Okie dokie...
Um...
Is there anything I wanna buy?
I...
Wait...
Cascade...
Connect the twin Kalina Ann's to fire a supercharged energy beam.
Whoa!
Hold the X.
Then release when they're together.
Okay...
Mod that makes his chair a plastic chair.
It became more popular than the real thing.
Ah, I see.
Well, how was I supposed to know?
How was I supposed to know to add a mod to a game that I've never played before?
Virgil has more Riz than Dante?
Um...
No, I think Dante just knows how to use protection.
That's what I think.
Dante...
Dante doesn't have children because he's safe.
And Virgil...
Virgil just doesn't have any...
Virgil will just leave you!
Dante has morals!
That's what I think!
Ok...
Um...
I don't think we need...
I think I understand...
We can at least see what it looks like.
This one.
Hold X together...
Get em girl!
Oh my god!
I like it.
Get em girl!
Try it on Gunslinger?
Oh, I forgot.
You're right.
Oh, there we go.
Wait, did I do that or...
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, I was gonna say, where'd he go?
Dead weight and dead beat.
Like father, like son, unfortunately.
All right, I think I'm just gonna go into it for now.
Actually, because I used King Cerberus in the last thing...
Let's see what else we got here.
On the ground, are we back?
Why?
Ah, what's this one again?
Okay.
Ice Age.
Back to forward.
Long Revolver.
Hold Y until electrified.
Let's get Revolver at least.
Oh, I can do more Revolver!
Longer distance and more violent spin.
I like it.
Revolver.
Um...
I'll probably get Crystal too, just to have...
Yeah, I think it'll be good.
Okay, that's good for now.
Good for now.
Chew on this!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh...
Morals over Riz.
That's what I'm saying.
Dante's a good guy.
I always like watching what they're doing in the little...
In the little menu...
Mission menus.
Like ladies always hanging out with Nico, it's so cute.
All right, three more!
We got this.
I forget though.
Wait, okay.
I think it's... you electrify it with...
Oh, oh.
Aw.
Time to go up.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, are these after me?
No?
Okay.
Oh!
It's these little bodies!
Are they...
Hey guys, where you been?
I thought you went back into Virgil.
Heh, you're gonna wish you did.
Oh, the wise guy Dante.
We were spawned from Virgil's abominable thoughts.
Truth howdy.
Come to think of it, I did know something was off.
Just like with my old brother.
Well, we're merely the discarded thoughts from when he was Neo Angelo.
No longer bound in his consciousness.
We're here now to kill you of our own free will.
I mean, you could join us too.
Oh.
Oh golly.
I wish I had never bought anything for you guys.
I wish I had never bought anything for you.
Oh.
Ouch.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Come here.
Come here, bird.
Wait.
Why am I...
Huh?
Wait.
What the heck?
My weapon.
Oh, there we go.
Finally.
Come here.
Ouchie, ouch!
Come on, come here.
Do I just kind of keep destroying this thing?
Why are you just getting started?
Oh my god.
You little wimp.
Can't wait for the rematch.
What a little wiener.
Weenie, weenie.
What a little weenie.
All of them weenies.
Oh my gosh, where'd you come from?
I missed it.
Here's all I already did.
Give him the hat.
Oh yeah, let's switch to our hat.
Oh, one more time.
Nothing.
Stingy.
All of these summons are the bosses from DMC1.
Yeah, someone told me about that last time too.
Virgil thinks about birds, cats, and goop monsters.
Okay.
Enter.
I love goop, and cats, and bird monsters.
Oh, nice.
Almost missed that.
Let's go.
Let's go, baby.
Yeah, yeah.
Shape-shifting panthers, and...
Weeer.
Oh, oh, shadow.
Are you going to be able to fight properly?
Oh my gosh, he is.
Because you also couldn't ever fight so well.
Hey, oh.
Why is it so misty over here?
Looks like a barrier.
Get him.
Yeah, get the Zayas.
Oh, that's it?
Come on.
Maybe it's, maybe it's not the...
Oh, that's me.
Maybe it's not the user, though.
Or maybe it is the user, I mean.
Oh, oh.
Hold on, I'm going to get the orb.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Damn.
Poor little shadow was being like...
Oh, hello.
Uh...
Wait.
I thought I heard another one.
No?
Uh, let's go...
Wait.
I do hear one.
Oh, he's up there.
I can't tell which way it wants me to go.
Oh.
I'll take those.
Wait.
Actually, let's, uh...
Do this.
Oh, no, no, no.
No, no.
Don't run away.
You're my money.
Wait.
I'm trying to donut you.
I'm...
I royally messed that up.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
I...
I royally screwed that one up.
I was trying to get all three of them at once.
So that one wouldn't de-spine.
You know what it means?
Instead.
Oh, shucks.
You can't win them all, you guys.
Oh, okay.
That's all that was down here.
You can't win them all.
More like royal goop.
What have I grown?
What'd you say about me?
Oh, sorry.
I'm on my mouse.
What'd you say about me?
You going full panic when you had to fight Shadow on DMC1.
Now look at you.
Big kitty.
It would help if I...
If I got close to it.
Where is that?
Oh.
Oops.
That doesn't sound good.
I'm sure it's fine.
Oh, you guys.
Come here.
You almost did.
Tilly's toast.
Very toast.
Oh, you're back.
Oh.
Hold on.
You would look great in this.
You would look great in that.
Yeah.
There's another one.
Game.
I'm lost.
Get him.
I'm...
No, what is auto?
No, no, no.
What did I just do?
Game.
I'm lost.
Is it this way?
I gotta go up?
I hear them up there.
Here, here, here, here.
Come here.
Here, here, here.
A little hat.
No, no, no.
Don't, don't, don't you dare.
Don't you dare.
Come back.
Wait, come here.
Don't you leave.
You're my money.
You're my business venture.
I need you.
Big money.
I think, I hope none of that dropped off the size.
I hope none of that.
And time for, what's his name?
Uh, big nightmare?
Is he here?
Oh, shadow.
Again?
Where are you?
Big kitty.
Ouch.
That was rude.
Oh, wait.
You're here, too?
Where are you?
Oh.
Where's the bird?
Oh, there he is.
Ouch.
Not a bad line.
You're the same way.
Oh.
Two with one stone.
Oh, my God.
I forgot you had that move.
I don't think I ever bought it for you.
Where'd you learn that from?
Cat in the hat.
It's so funny looking.
Hey.
Woo.
Where did you learn that?
I never taught my kitty how to do that.
Oh.
Nice.
There's a manga covering Virgil's story?
Really?
Let's focus on Cat.
Oh, only Cat.
Oh.
Only Cat.
Check out Vision of V.
One more round.
Looks like I'm back on Malay Island.
Malay, Malay.
Malay.
Malay the island.
Oh, nice.
Punch the Cat in the face.
Yeah, pretty much.
Actually, no.
I nunchucked the Cat in the face.
Big difference.
Whoa.
I almost missed.
It pays to be observant.
Right, Dante?
I guess also putting a little hat on and doesn't do anything since...
They're not technically dying right now.
Do you remember the island?
Put the one
in...
Oh.
They know they don't stand a chance.
Are they trying to atone for something?
Oh.
Take it.
You know what?
Why not?
How have I seen so many playthroughs of this game and never come across a cat in the hatch?
I'm going to charge my...
Charge my...
Okay.
We're going to charge before we...
Before we fight the nightmare.
Oh, come on.
It's so low.
They're like, hey, remember his cane?
He's gone now.
You'll never see him again.
This guy was also...
A jerk!
You know what?
I don't feel like dealing with you guys.
I don't feel like dealing with you guys right now.
Oh,
shoot.
I lost it.
Ouch!
Wait.
Oh.
You had me in your little claws!
And you...
Pull three of them at once is kind of...
Oh.
Wait.
What if I...
How was it?
It was like, hold down X, no?
Oh, and Gunslinger.
Oh.
You're just tapping me a lot.
Let's try it.
Oh.
Oh, I had to buy it.
I don't remember.
Be honest.
Oh.
Stupid bird.
Why is their health not going down at all, though?
Oh my god.
Oh, is it just him that I have to...
Nightmare's the main body.
I see.
Okay.
What is he?
Oh.
Ouch.
Oh, I'm scared.
What's he gonna do?
Ow!
That's me!
Oh, he's spinning.
Oh,
come on!
I was in front of you.
How did that hit?
Oh.
Ow!
I missed it again.
Woo-wee.
Woo!
No!
Okay, I need to just DT normal.
I need to just DT normal.
Input's a little wonky.
Sometimes I would press it, and it really didn't do it.
I need tosemlle is G-w as he - Noooo!
Woo, that gave some blobs.
I'll take that.
Freeze!
Fience!
Yeah!
Yeah, freeze!
Oh, wait, get the...
get the...
Get the...
Get them!
Here he comes.
Wait, the cat's back!
Oh gosh.
Where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
Don't do it.
What a waste of my DT, you mister!
You made me waste my DT!
I'm gonna switch back to my dungeon.
Oh my gosh!
Get up, get up!
As soon as I started, he was in it.
Oh, he's gone!
Seriously?
Oh wait, he's right there.
Get his butt, get his butt!
Yeah!
He became orbed!
Get orbed!
You should've known better.
You got a good heart, but you're about as sharp as a marble.
Oh, dang.
Perhaps.
But if you had even a little bit of trouble defeating us...
No!
None!
No trouble!
I can see you guys commenting that on my...
Saying, you're about as sharp as a marble.
Rest in peace, little chicken.
Aw, fried chicken on the menu.
Don't 07 him.
He sucked.
I'm sti- I'm not over the betrayal.
I'm still upset about it.
Oh my god, Niko!
I don't know if that's better or worse!
Where's Dante?
He's got this!
We gotta go, now!
So this guy Virgil, you know him?
Vaguely.
Yes.
Dante said that guy's my father.
What the hell's going on, Trish?
His logic is sound.
I had a hunch myself.
What?
This doesn't make any sense!
It's the Griffin's voice actor who passed away in 2020.
I know you're a virgin, but you can't kill your own father!
It's true.
You'd never recover from that.
She would know.
Lady would know.
You saved us.
You should be proud.
Now you can put all this behind me.
Niko, stop the car!
No chance!
After all this, are you insane?
Lady...
Oh, lady!
Gosh, she's so beautiful.
Fine.
I'll go by myself.
I'm gonna have to fight...
I'm gonna have to kill him as Nero, huh?
Also, why would she stop the car when the whole place is literally collapsing?
He's about as sharp as a marble.
Oh, no.
Mission 19 is Dante.
Which means mission 20 is gonna be Nero!
No!
Oh, man.
I really don't know if there's anything else I could get that would make a difference for me.
I don't know.
Wait, it was this one.
That's right.
Would it even... would it even...
I don't know if I already bought the last one.
I bought all that I could.
Huh...
Nero is Johnny Young Vash.
Yeah!
I barely even used Trickster, guys.
I don't think it would.
I'm not gonna start now.
I don't know if I'll start now if I don't use it before.
If I... if I... I mean, I have the money, though.
I think everybody who's telling me to use Royal Guard...
...haven't watched me before.
Just play as you always have.
I guess that's true.
Yeah.
You know what?
That's... I've gotten through it before.
I've withered by...
...sheer...
...determination...
...uh...
...and...
...determination...
...frustration...
...motivation...
...hahaha...
...and money.
Oh no!
I haven't spent money.
I spent gorbs.
And that's different.
Because those... have all been free.
Gorbs...
...are free.
I collected those myself.
And yogurt.
Yogurt!
Oh my gosh.
I don't know if I'll make it.
I'm not gonna lie.
I don't know if I'll make it for yogurt time.
Since I have two missions left.
But we'll see.
We'll see, we'll see.
I'm just gonna go in.
Let's just go in then and see what happens.
Get motivated.
Get motivated!
Do you guys remember that from... Ajumanga Daioh but it was in the dub.
And Chio-chan is like, get motivated!
Get motivated!
Oh so in the... in the mod, he would be sitting in a plastic chair?
Should I... Should I... Wait.
Oh, shoot.
I just quit.
Hold on.
Wait.
Should I... Should I quit and install the mod?
No?
Okay, then let me read... Let me redo.
Since I actually quit... I tried to pause it and I actually quit the cutscene.
Okay.
Not a good use of time.
Yeah, guys!
We're on a time limit!
True.
I'll just look it up later.
If you want... Then you'll have to take it.
But you already knew that.
Yeah, I know.
I had a feeling you'd say that.
Yeah.
Gosh.
Virgil aged so gracefully.
How many times have we fought?
If turning... If separating your humanity...
Hard to say.
It's the only memory I have of us since we were kids.
And your demon form...
Makes it so that you stop aging.
It'll be great.
Time to finish this, Virgil.
Once and for all.
Oh, it's all the human blood sacrifices.
I won't lose to the rights of you.
Oh, why am I carrying this giant...
Oh.
Meow.
Oh my golly.
I feel like I should fight him with Dante.
I'm slow.
Oh, I remember that.
Cool.
Where's your motivation?
Give him the hat.
Wait.
No.
No, no.
Come here.
Wait.
Oh.
Sorry.
Hold on.
I'm messing it up.
He doesn't want it!
I'm gonna cry.
No.
Foolishness.
Whoop.
Ow.
Oops.
I did not realize what was happening.
Ugh.
Nine.
If I DT, can he DT?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, shoot.
What kind of fool are you?
Is that what he just said?
Oh.
Ouchy, ouch.
Stop with me.
Let's end this, Dante.
No, no, no!
Get up, Dante!
Oh my gosh.
Ouchy, ouch.
Ouch.
Come on.
I was running.
Okay.
I'm scared to use it.
I'm not gonna lie.
Scum.
My health.
You're forced.
Oh.
I should've used it.
Scum.
Yeah, for now.
Use the gold...
Gorbs here?
Maybe.
I'll try...
I wanna try one more time.
And then we can use Gorbs, you know?
Hmm.
I won't lose to the likes of you, little brother.
Oh my god.
I tried to...
Oh my...
Take that.
Yeah.
Too slow.
Says you.
Excuse me?
Oh.
I'm...
I mistimed that so badly.
It's fine.
Ugh.
I don't know what I was thinking, to be honest.
Oh.
What are you doing close...
So close to me?
Don't move.
Oi!
You're finished.
Oh, ow.
Ugh.
I forgot that it has this now.
The...the...what's it called?
The extra...
Ever since I became...
Ultra powerful.
Awesome.
Cool.
Foolish.
Ouch!
Why does it feel so hard to get...
To get...what's it called right now?
Scam.
Oh boy.
Oh no.
Wait, I can't.
That's so unfair.
No, no, no.
I can't right now.
No, no.
This is so unfair.
Hahaha.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, wait.
No, no, no.
I'm a dodging queen.
Hahaha.
I'm scared.
What is he gonna do?
Prepare.
To die.
Uh.
Where's he going?
Oh.
Oh, I...
Oh, that took so much.
Wait.
What the hell?
Oh my god.
Wait.
I bet the DT.
I tried the DT.
Holy hell.
I pressed...I pressed it.
It didn't go through.
So that's it.
Hold on.
I wanna try that though.
Oh.
Uh.
You guys...
Everybody's play styles are different, okay?
So...
Just remember that.
You guys...
If you don't like it, you don't gotta watch.
That's okay.
You know?
Do it.
I feel...
How far did I get with his health?
I felt...
What was it like?
A little...
Yogurt.
Yogurt!
About halfway.
Ah.
Let me do one more.
50% is not bad.
Yogurt.
What if I need all 16 for the last boss?
What if I need all 16?
Okay, let's go back.
Oh.
Come on.
And I did pretty well with having...
With not taking any damage for...
For the first part.
Except this, you know.
Ah!
Oh.
Oop.
That kinda sucked.
Yelp!
Yeah!
Foolishness.
Scum.
Aw.
You...
Whee!
Oh.
Yeah!
Alright.
And I'm saving my...
DT!
I'm wondering if I should...
I'm trying to decide if I wanna have it for like...
It's DT or...
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, golly.
Okay.
Is there any point?
Oh, golly.
He ran out way sooner than I did.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Or I ran out rather...
I ran out way sooner than he did!
Woo hoo hoo hoo wee!
Uh oh.
Fine, I'll use trickster!
Good job guys.
Good trickster.
I think it helps to read him better.
Wait, what am I... Holy!
Ouch!
How did that hit me?!
Ugh, Sam.
Yeah.
I don't know, I feel so comfortable using it.
Okay, what I'm gonna do is... Oh, wait.
Is... I'm gonna actually... We're gonna go with the big boy.
Maybe next time.
Oh, golly.
Okay, I just gotta dodge.
Oh, shit.
So much for that.
Wait, now if I do this...
Wait, he's not even hitting him.
Wait, hit him.
Okay, that did good damage.
But I have so little health now.
Whoa, so cool.
Okay, come here.
Okay, I'm gonna... You're so powerful, Virgil!
Oh, my God.
He just DT'd again.
You!
That's so unfair.
How do you have so much DT?
Huh?
How do you have it?
Is he healing?
If he is, it's very slow.
Yeah,
but not as... Ouch!
Ouch!
Oh!
There I go.
Wait.
I'm still in the game!
My son means nothing to me.
Aww.
Poor...
Mero.
Come on, man.
Come on...
Oh!
No!
I really should have DT'd.
It's okay, though.
I'll use a Gorb.
It's okay.
I was too distracted.
Oh, wait.
Why did I do that now?
I don't know.
Hold on.
What the?
What is this?
What is...
Wait!
I couldn't even see!
The...the...the camera!
I don't even know...I thought it was still in the cutscene!
Are you kidding me?
I can't...I can't see anything!
Oh, there.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait!
Ouch.
He's not even DT'd anymore.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, my gosh.
We're so close, guys.
Yeah!
It's a victory!
Oh!
Oh, that was sad.
Oi, oi, oi, oi!
I almost had him.
Oh!
Run!
Run, run, run!
Dante, run!
Oh, my God!
That was so close!
Hahaha!
Come on!
You can do it!
Aaaaah!
Not him, DT!
I guess it is so...
Hahaha!
Oops.
Eh?
Oh, no, no, no...
Please...
Oh, my God!
He healed so much!
I
can't believe I almost had that fight and I completely... What are these?
What the hell is this?!
What is going on?
Wait, why can't I move?
Why is this happening?!
Huh?!
Why
couldn't I move?!
Why couldn't I go...?
I got stuck!
Done?!
Oh my god... I was... I was so mad that I had him!
I... I HAD HIM!
I'm gonna... Whatever, though.
It's okay.
Two endless forms...
It was all my fault.
I completely... I fumbled it so hard.
I had it!
And I fumbled it so hard!
It's because I'm in fucking Trickster!
That's why!
Are you coming out?
Just SDT?
Okay.
Let's get him with a big move at the end, huh?
Yee-haw!
That's
not how that's supposed to work.
Hello.
Hero.enz it, girl. my son.
Uh... Yeah!
... dumbass!
You should remember though that thick skull of yours?
I was doing... Hey.
Dante!
seemed tired.
That's not bad.
I was doing better.
Oh!
Wow!weh!
That was a long time ago.
Hahaha!
I guess you were young once too?
Aw.
As much as I'd love to hear that story... I think it's about time we... ended this.
Oh my god!
They finished each other's sandwiches.
You died twice!
Uh!
Not at the end!
I was!..
riesengiging voices down!
I was like this.
What are you talking about?
Virgil also gorbed.
He did.
Raiden.
What?
No.
No way.
Little baby.
Is it my... It's gotta be my little baby.
It's my little baby.
The brotherhood defined by hatred and grudging respect.
True power.
Oh my god, he can finally DT once again.
Wow, it's only been three hours.
Like, I remember when it said 1 p.m.
On like the clock.
Is that you, Nero?
He's calling his girl.
Did something happen?
Aww.
Kiria, you must not live here.
When I was a kid, I... I was alone.
He's calling his girl for support.
You and Cradle were all I knew.
Oh, a credit card.
And now, all of a sudden, I find out I have a family.
What am I supposed to do with that?
You always know which path is right.
There's no need to doubt yourself.
Thanks.
I guess that's all I needed to hear.
No.
I have one last thing to take care of.
Can you imagine if she's like, wait, Nero, I have one more thing to tell you.
You have a...
And then got cut off.
I'm...
I'm Greg.
Cut off.
To this day.
I hate myself for not having enough strength.
But this time is different.
He's a lizard.
His stand.
Woo!
He could finally...
Curious.
Nero.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, Papa.
The power of family.
That's what keeps those movies.
Uh, the...
Oh, my gosh.
What...
Oh, gosh.
What are those racing movies?
I can't remember.
Why am I...
I told you already.
This is not your...
Oh!
Jeez!
Fast and Furious.
Thank you.
I'm so stupid.
Can't even hold up my own joke.
I won't let you kill each other.
There are other ways of settling your differences.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Is the final boss fight therapy?
Final boss fight is you picking the right answers in therapy.
You came all this way just for that.
Dead weight.
Virgil.
V.
Whatever you call yourself.
Dante's not gonna die here.
And neither are you.
Papa?
You have a problem with that.
Not gonna die my ass.
Oh.
That bitch slap nearly killed me.
If I beat Nero.
Then by default.
I beat you.
Agreed Dante.
What?
Whatever.
I don't really care.
I'm just gonna sit this one out.
Let my own man rest.
Okay.
What?
When this is over.
I'll make you submit.
Father.
Not the ghostly knuckle crab.
I'm gonna die.
Oh.
This has nothing to do with you.
Stand down.
Nothing to do with me.
That has everything to do with me.
Oh gosh.
Wait.
D-pad.
Add when DT gage is at 3.
Ow, it's a...
D-pad?
Wait...
Press RT near staggered enemy.
Perform a buster.
Oh, oh, I am... I'm pressing...
Ah, he's not staggered.
I guess, I'm staggered enough.
Oh, RT!
I'm so stupid.
I thought it was RB.
Okay, we'll do it next time.
Oh shoot.
Get out of there.
Oh, what a waste.
What a waste.
Oh yeah, I don't have a grabby arm anymore.
I just noticed.
Okay.
Oh, let's turn.
Oh no!
Oh, I forgot he could GT too.
RT, V2, please!
I didn't even realize!
I'm sorry!
I'm getting used to it!
They just threw this at me!
Please!
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my gosh, I can even...
Even get him when he is DT'd.
Seed.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm waiting.
I got both of them!
Holy hell!
Oh my god.
How
am I supposed to dodge these now?
Just run faster, I suppose.
Grab him?
Can I?
Well, that didn't happen.
RT here.
Oh, oh my...
Oh, wait!
Come on, bud!
Zero!
Scum.
How does he have so much DT?
Oh my god.
Bang, bang, bang!
I'm trying to move!
Okay.
Where are you?
Ah, shoot.
Oh my goodness.
Ah!
Please!
Why!
Why?!
Oh my...
Oh shoot.
Oh my goodness...
Please!
Oh my gosh.
Why can't I do the last scoop?
You have a gun, that's so lame!
Oh, this is even more lame maybe.
I'm so upset right now.
I can't even think.
Oh, that's the wrong thing.
Where are you?
I need a second.
Okay.
I don't know why my brain doesn't work.
Like, I don't know why sometimes my...
My brain and my hands don't work.
It's so frustrating!
I don't know why my brain is running.
Okay.
RT.
Yeah!
Yeah.
Oh, and he's gone.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, I know that the DT is recharging, so I'm just going to do it as much as I... whenever it's good, you know?
Oh my goodness.
Oh.
Oh, I hate.
I hate.
Wow, he has so much DT.
But I like... If I can get him down... Okay, here we go.
Yeah!
Holy... Did that even... Did me DT'ing during that even change it?
Ha ha ha.
Scum.
Oh.
I was too slow.
Oh, shoot.
He did that.
I'm letting it recharge more.
Oh.
I have to grab him, right?
Okay.
I... I am pressing it.
I promise.
I'm pressing it.
I am.
I'm RT'ing.
I'm RT'ing, I promise.
It must be a very tight window.
Oh.
Oy.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
Ah.
Shoot.
DT.
Sorry.
Yeah, I wish we're good.
Come on!
Oh, man.
Eheheheh.
Oh, please.
Oh, ah.
I've never seen him DT this long.
He's so... He's cheating?
Is this the extent of your power?
He... I feel like in the second half, he's DT'ed the whole time, no?
Can you snatch him when he blocks?
I'll try.
Gold him.
Okay.
If you guys allow me to.
Who are you?
Oh, oh.
Now he's back to normal.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
I can't even see.
Please.
Where are you?
Oh, my God.
Oh.
And he's back, too.
Wait.
This is so unfair.
I'm trying to grab him.
It didn't work.
Unless it's like a...
Woo.
It's not working.
I don't know why.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, thank goodness.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
Interesting.
How does he have so much DT?
Oh, my God.
Oh, honey.
How?
Enough, damn it.
Uhhh.
The underworld is taking over.
We need to do something before it's too late.
We need an apple.
An apple a day keeps the Virgil away.
Stinking.
And what's annoying about that last fight, what was making me so frustrated is they give you so much.
And it was just my inability.
That's what was making me so upset about it.
He's been collecting those plorbs.
I know.
You can't just expect me to stay here while you both go and...
It's because you're here we can go.
We're trusting you with things on this side.
Capiche?
Capiche.
Make haste Dante.
Yeah, I know.
Hey, wait!
You didn't say capiche!
Oh no!
Next time.
Hold on to that until then.
My silly brothers!
It's full of BL.
That's what I was thinking too.
I don't feel satisfied at all, but...
It's okay.
Same.
Me too.
Yeah, that's what I said!
That's true.
That is true.
Do you know how much love and care I put in that devil breaker?
Nope.
With this arm?
That's nice.
Heh heh.
So, uh, how's it feel?
Yeah, Virgil literally going to hell so that he doesn't have to pay child support.
You're saving the man who killed your own father.
Heard Dante killed Virgil once.
Yeah, but he's still here.
It doesn't matter.
We're both gone now anyway.
Aw, Dante.
It's okay to cry.
If you want, Nero, over a loss.
Not cry.
It doesn't make you a cry, baby.
It does make you a little bitch, though.
There it is.
Heh heh.
You think I'm a demon?
I didn't cry when my asshole daddy died.
Yeah, I did that, sorry.
But...
Yeah, I know, I know.
I wouldn't be here without him.
That's a biological fact.
Right.
All I'm saying is, tough guy.
It's okay to cry if you want.
I'm not crying.
Devils cry.
I'm not gonna cry.
Meow.
But will you cry?
Woo!
Why don't you cry on my shoulder?
Stop saying cry.
I don't cry on my shoulder.
I know you wanna...
Woo!
Kitty's crying.
Meow!
Keep sitting.
Kitty-ay.
She's pregnant.
Yeah.
I'm coming home.
She's pregnant.
You have an announcement.
I don't wanna spoil it, but I got a surprise for you.
He's pregnant!
Shut up!
No, no, no, Kitty-ay.
Not you.
Niko.
You know.
And her big mouth.
What the hell's your problem?
Where'd you learn to drive?
You gotta clean up the town.
Sorry, I gotta call you later.
Time to get back to work.
Mm-hmm.
You gotta clean up, Miro.
Didn't you learn anything?
I can't believe it.
He's pregnant!
Got an arm.
I'm good.
It's a prototype.
Oh.
And this is the perfect place to test it out.
Look, you're gonna use it...
Oh, no.
The timer.
Oh, God.
It's the timer.
Wait.
I have to pee so bad.
How sweet.
Ooh.
Feels good.
What are we listening to?
You'll get fixed as soon as we get back.
We're not listening to anything.
So, devils cry, huh?
Let's see what that sounds like!
Yeah!
Gotta let it out.
Oh, she's...
What's it do?
Wow!
Wait, there's so many...
Wait.
Press X?
What are you...
I can't read this...
I can't read this text!
I can't read this!
What the hell?
I can't read all of this!
Oh, my God!
You're not showing me!
I'm quick and I DT!
DT?
Nope.
Just do it.
Oh, when I have the wings.
Okay.
Oh.
I'm a double checker!
Just gonna tell you now, guys.
We're probably not gonna reach that timer, but...
Wait.
Come here.
Oh, it's gone.
Let me DT, please!
Oh, we can RT things, too?
Oh, my God!
I didn't even think about that!
I
forgot about the RT!
Wait, I did it?
I did it!
Guess that's the end, then.
So all we gotta do is cut this thing down.
That's right!
I'm more than capable of handling this on my own.
It's not over yet?
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
I could've peed so bad.
This game is not friendly to the small bladder.
But wait, there's more!
Okay.
Hi!
Hold!
But these are not so bad.
These are kinda easy, right?
And we're doing it with Virgil.
That guy is...
That guy can handle his own.
They must be ready for that.
Uh, yeah.
Fine by me.
Let's give them what they want.
Oh, please.
Get all of them?
Yeah, oh.
Can I also DT?
No.
Or, uh, wait.
I guess I can.
Oh, shoot.
I can't see with all this text on the screen.
Are you doing anything, Virgil?
Are you doing your job?
I can't see.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
It's going.
Oh, oh, shoot.
I can SDT, but how do I even know?
What are you doing over there?
Oh my gosh, I can't even move.
I can't.
I'm trying to get out of here.
Oh my god, please let me out.
Oh, oh, what did I switch to?
I somehow switched to...
the thing.
Oh, this might be good.
Woo, woo!
Stop blocking.
I can't see...
Yes.
Fight with Nero.
Okay.
I didn't.
It's okay.
Let me go pee.
Please, let me go pee.
whoops.
Yay!
Are you sorry?
That would're good.
How do we learn?
I...
A way?
Standing beside you.
There is no mountain too tall to overcome.
We will be as one.
You will rise again.
This is your legacy.
Ah!
I feel so much better.
Oh my goodness.
Wow.
I remember that place.
Should I wash your hands?
I always wash my hands.
Almost got that secret ending.
I don't know.
It's okay, though.
It's all good.
We did it.
Oh.
I'm blocking her, but little Niko is behind her truck.
The truck is huge.
Can you see it?
I'm too... I'm blocking it.
There we go.
This is my leg.
Oh, there they are.
Oh, look at them.
How cute.
I mean, the thing has a shower in there.
A workshop.
It's huge.
Well, she's tiny.
It's an RV.
Yeah.
RV.
I said truck.
I meant RV.
I don't recognize any of the names in the JP translation.
Or JP dub.
Who would you rather have as a dad?
Virgil or Angus Beef?
I don't know.
Moral of the story?
Use protection.
Yeah.
So true.
If you have a kid...
Pay the child support if you choose to abandon him.
Akio Otsuka was Morrison.
Wait, I didn't even see his name.
No way.
I was looking for him.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm so tired.
My brain is mush.
I don't think I have the energy to drive to...
To drive to...
Yogurt.
Oh, boy.
Oh, son of Sparta.
Bloody palace.
No, thank you.
Recovery provocation.
Nero's demonic right arm has been restored.
And he can now both...
Use both devil bringer and devil trigger.
Wait, what about like...
What about tomboy?
Dante can equip rebellion, devil sword Sparta, or devil sword Dante.
Oh, my gosh.
Nico's reports...
Enemy reports have expanded to include photos capturing the moment of an enemy's defeat.
Oh, that's exciting.
You use all of it at once.
Costume changes.
The last costume you played...
Wait, I didn't change costumes, though.
I can use everything now.
Go get that yogurt, champ.
Thank you.
I'm so tired.
Wait, hold on.
There's a gallery, right?
Let me see.
Wait, did he have the wings?
No, shut up.
Wait, where's my...
Where's the gallery?
Main menu?
Oh, it wasn't there.
I was in the main menu.
Oh, here, here, here.
Okay, okay.
Gallery.
Oh, excuse me?
Everybody's here.
You are not welcome.
V.
You are unwelcome here.
Get out of here.
Get out of my car.
He pisses me off the most.
Nico's report.
Oh, my gosh.
Peter Thickups.
Thank you for the spooky.
Don't know.
Thank you.
I'm graduating from college on May 10th.
Well, congratulations.
Congratulations.
Sorry, I don't have more energy right now.
One-armed Nero.
Nero.
Restored Nero.
Wow, he's got an arm.
Devil-trigger Nero.
Whoa.
Wow.
Model Nero.
There we go.
Whoa.
Nice.
You can...
You can get a handful of that.
Dante.
Awakened Dante.
Hey, I'm Dante.
Hi, I'm Dante.
I just woke up.
Ha ha ha ha.
Devil-trigger Dante.
Shit.
Here we go.
This is the real pro...
God.
Golly.
Wait.
No, no, no.
Oh my god.
Wow.
Oh, he's got...
Guys.
It's fine.
This is...
This might be the greatest...
Greatest...
Greatest bum...
In video gaming history.
Ha ha ha ha.
V is just...
Dying.
V.
Ha ha ha.
Yeah.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Wait.
There we go.
Yeah.
You're dying.
Ha ha ha ha.
I didn't mean to zoom in on his crotch.
Ha ha ha.
Wait.
Do we have shower lady?
Lady Infantile.
Oh my god.
She's so cute.
Yeah.
My clothes look a little baggy on her.
But that's just because she's the scrawny type.
Don't mean I'm heavy or nothing.
She's so stinking cute.
Wait.
What's the difference?
Oh, clean face.
Oh my gosh.
She's so cute.
Waaah.
I love lady.
Look at her lips here.
Oh.
What about Trish?
Oh my gosh.
We even get Morrison.
We get...
We even get to see Morrison.
He's like, I got one look.
That's all I got.
I do wish her scar was a bit more visible.
I actually agree.
I agree.
I wish her scar was a little bit more visible too.
Whoa.
Dante's looking very...
Castlevania here.
Ew.
Oh my gosh.
You're so cute.
I think you skipped the post-credits scene.
Wait.
There's an actual post-credits scene?
I didn't skip anything though.
If you're talking about the secret ending, I...
Wait.
I didn't skip anything though.
But if you're talking about the secret one, I didn't get it because I failed the second part.
You have to beat Virgil in the last bit.
Yeah.
See guys?
I didn't get it.
So.
I did not get it.
You skipped it.
I didn't press anything.
How could I have skipped it?
It took me straight back to the menu.
I didn't press anything.
You guys are being...
You guys are being a little much right now.
Okay?
You guys need to chill.
They're sad you didn't see it.
Yeah.
But...
Um...
It's okay.
I don't need to see it right now.
You know?
It's okay.
It's all good.
Don't get one guy.
I was reading a super chat.
I just wanted to let them know.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I don't feel so well, you guys.
So.
That's why I'm kind of low energy.
But I just wanted to look through the art.
I like it better with her things on.
The...
What's it called?
Like all the...
I can't think anymore.
Virgil.
He looks sickly here.
The mommy.
Nightmare.
Nero and DT.
Her layers.
Yeah.
The music's putting me to sleep.
It's so chill.
Oh.
These guys are so sick looking.
These are the...
This...
The...
This guy.
Yeah.
I was going to say the Grim Reaper looking guys.
Oh.
I never noticed the face changes.
That's neat.
This guy.
I like this guy.
He's cool.
Oh.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
This is great.
Oh.
I liked...
That lady too.
Urinal.
Malthus.
Screw that bird.
Hate that bird.
Too much bird.
Not enough sexy lady.
It's like...
Oh my gosh.
It's just like before.
In...
In four.
Except...
I feel like if we had a good amount of sexy lady.
What was...
Uh...
Chicken Jackie.
King Cerberus.
Blue Rose.
The V's came.
Ebony and Ivory.
I never knew that they had the pictures of...
The ladies on them.
No.
Not the plant lady.
Um...
The...
The fishy guy.
The angler fishy guy.
Oh my god.
Imagine being the one...
Who receives this image...
And they're just like...
Render that in 3D.
The frog!
Yeah.
He was a frog.
It was so gross.
Make this in 3D now.
Dr. Faust.
So many...
Small details.
Never even notice.
I'd quit.
Nah.
I believe in you.
Oh wow.
We get to see it when it's like...
Actually...
In motion.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Helter Skelter.
Wow.
Oh see.
That's really cool.
You never...
I never thought about like...
How it looked when it was...
Like...
You know...
Being...
When it was working.
It's so fast.
Everything's so fast.
Gerbera.
Lulu from Final Fantasy X...
Has a dress made of bells.
Yeah.
Because like...
I wanted to see if the team...
Could render it in the game.
Oh.
That's so rude.
Like the guy...
Oh gosh.
What's his name?
Uh...
Kingdom Hearts.
Nomura.
That's so evil.
Design meeting.
Oh yeah.
I can totally interpret what that is.
Fancy.
We saw this for all of...
Two seconds.
Oh.
That's cool.
That's so cool.
Wait.
It was their house?
The whole time.
I never...
Wow.
Oh my god.
That's such an awesome detail.
It's kind of crazy seeing how much more of the city gets destroyed over time.
Phantom.
That's me.
Nero looking like Eminem out in here.
Spider-Man.
I remember that part.
I remember that.
Ooh.
You played all DMC to save the DMC reboot.
Time for Bayonetta.
Gonna have to play him on Switch.
The Bayonetta eventually.
Remember all these areas.
Oh, that's so sad.
He's reaching out.
Little baby.
We got robbed of seeing baby Dante.
I remember that guy.
No.
Villa always looks so pathetic in these...
In these...
Concept art pieces.
Virgil was always just a traumatized kid.
Seeking power to protect and validate himself.
He's so tsundere.
Oh.
Moments before disaster.
I'm carrying me.
Nice.
Others.
Oh.
I want to talk to whoever...
Whoever...
What sicko...
Redesigned the...
The blorbs and the...
What sicko...
Redesigned these.
Roarb looks okay, I guess.
But the blorb is unforgivable.
But also...
Why is the gorb a cube?
And what the hell is a borb?
And the warb...
I think gorb goes kind of hard.
It looks like that one angel from Evangelion.
The blorb is insane.
It's so ugly.
Oh, it's so funny.
The porb is fine.
But the...
The warb is also horrible.
Y'all know I can watch the...
The anime.
The reboot and Netflix show aren't bad, but up to you if you want to watch them.
I do want to watch them.
Maybe I'll watch along.
We'll see.
Thank you, Mobjin, for the pink.
Thank you so much.
Love how everyone's chill with Virgil after he massacres the city for a second time.
This is just...
Devil may cry things.
You know, baby Dante had Sparta's haircut.
Whoa.
Those orbs would make a great fruit snack design.
They would!
Warb is a mood.
That's how I feel right now.
Who had crazier brother complex?
Virgil or Liquid?
I think if Liquid had the power...
To do what Virgil could, he would.
I
don't think...
Virgil didn't do everything that he did to get back at Dante.
But Liquid totally did.
Liquid totally was just like, yeah, I'm going to get back at...
My brother.
With the better genes.
That he didn't actually have.
There's a manga.
Yeah, yeah.
Someone told me about it earlier.
The Harvested.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Those were a bunch of dead people that we definitely saw...
In the city.
Like, the whole city just pretty much got obliterated.
Wait, are we going to see the little...
Oh, gosh.
This game is horrible for anybody that has that fear of...
Of holes.
The trypophobia.
This game is horrible.
For anybody with that.
Liquid was in an arm.
Virgil removed an arm.
Everybody who had a vacation from the city.
We're lucky.
Congrats.
I'm beating the game.
Thank you.
I think you're also...
The first streamer I've seen actually win the Nero time challenge at the end.
Wait, I didn't win though.
I didn't win it.
I did it.
Oh, the Nero one.
I won Nero.
Sorry, you're right.
Sorry, I was thinking Virgil.
I did win Nero's part.
Yeah.
I did that.
I did win Nero's.
We take those.
Jukebox.
Public enemy.
Ultraviolet.
Lock and load.
Fire away.
So many that I didn't get.
Devil May Cry 3, 2...
Oh, wait.
I just noticed.
Oh, my God.
That's so fun.
Stylish voice.
Hey.
Never mind.
Wait.
It literally says bye.
Oh, you're kidding me.
Wow.
Okay.
Yeah, I don't think I ever won the timed challenges at the end ever before in any of the other games.
So, being able to get the one was nice, at least.
I will look up the ending.
And we can watch it together.
The one that I missed.
We'll watch it together.
And, uh...
Yeah.
Let me see.
Hold on.
Devil May Cry 5, secret ending.
Uh...
Let me just make sure...
Did I say smake sure?
Let me make sure these are good, you know?
Thank you, Jay!
Congrats on completing another game.
29 games to go.
28 if you count Visage.
Oh, yeah.
I guess I can count that, huh?
Why does this one feel so squished?
Hold on.
Let me try this instant.
Uh...
Fake me!
Thank you!
Not only did you beat the MC5, but the whole series.
Now, we beat the whole game.
Me.
I'm not a fighting game person ever.
And somehow, I brute force my way through.
Somehow.
Somehow, I brute force.
Special edition new ending.
I can't tell which one of these is.
The thing to watch.
I'll be honest.
I can't tell.
They're all giving me...
There's...
Watch them both.
No, there's like so...
It's like...
This is showing me all endings.
And it's 15 minutes long.
Congratulations.
Thank you!
Fourth warp!
Thank you.
Let me try after credits scene.
Instead, after credits.
Post credits scene.
Okay, this looks like it might be it.
It's 3 minutes 32 seconds.
Let me make sure that I don't...
Does it start with lady?
Gotta let it out.
Yeah?
Okay.
I'm gonna quit the game.
So that...
It's not playing in the background.
And let me pull it up.
Let me pull it up.
I'm so hungry.
Oh, I'm so hungry.
Let's see.
Hold on.
I'm gonna do this.
I'm cropping it right now.
And...
Okay, that should be good.
Oh, wait.
I didn't check to see if I can hear anybody.
No, it seems okay.
Okay.
Alright.
Uh, we watch.
Oh, let me get my head out of the way.
There we go.
A few weeks later.
July...
Pizza!
Too bad it's not Pizza Friday.
Wow.
No sign of them.
Nothing.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Haha.
Then can I have this office?
Because I've been thinking it's almost time for me to settle down somewhere.
Hmm.
No.
I don't think so.
The girls are growing.
Oh.
I hate to spoil your dreams, ladies, but that shit ain't gonna happen.
What do you mean, Morrison?
They're shutting off the lights.
See, there's a thing to this place, and I have it.
Oh.
Why do you...
Clever little devil came to see me right before his last job.
Said something like, My dearest friend, I know you'll keep this safe because them crazy bitches...
Did I say crazy bitches?
I'm sorry, I meant ladies.
Anyway, the rest of the story is not important.
No, that's definitely what Dante said.
I wonder if he even plans on coming back.
Got me.
What is important is I have a job for you two.
Ooh.
Lady is so stinking cute.
My goodness.
Oh my god.
Give it a rest.
They're bonding.
score for Dante.
I'm up one.
Way did you learn to count.
We're even.
You know, I'm starting to think this is never going to end.
Maybe.
We got plenty of time.
Why, why even?
What's the boy?
Thank you, Outsu.
Because they like to.
I know those guys.
That's a good visual.
I don't care what this person's points are.
Jackpot.
That's such a good visual right here.
Oh, not that.
Right there.
Woohoo!
Oh my gosh, I love that there's a video called Devil May Cry All Lady and Trish cutscenes.
So real.
So true.
So valid.
Yeah!
I know.
This pit goes hard.
It does!
It goes so hard.
Okay, guys.
I'm so hungry.
I'm so tired.
I might be able to make it to yogurt.
But I gotta eat it first if I want to try.
So thank you!
For Devil May Cry.
We'll see about the MC Devil May Cry.
I still don't know yet.
But I'm still feeling a little bleh.
So I think I just need to rest having having double Devil May Cry.
This game drains me so much in having it two days in a row.
Oh!
Has made me... Oh, I feel like I ran a marathon.
I feel like I've ran a marathon.
We trying the reboot too?
Maybe just to say that I've tried it.
I know that it has mixed feelings.
But I'm a bit of a completionist in terms of trying stuff and saying that I've tried it.
I don't want to have... I don't want to give anybody...
Any time someone's just like, oh, well, you didn't play such and such.
I'll be like, yeah.
I did.
Be safe, Mito, if you go get yogurt.
I'm already dead.
It's okay.
Thank you, guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I will see you guys... When I see you next!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Bye bye!
See you!